wanna be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you
know you're capable of more you've got
michael jordan level genius at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and get some
amazing motivation from jay shetty
enjoy
[Music]
you talked about the fear of fear and
how you had to learn to let go of
your fear of fear what does actually
mean letting go of the fear of
fear yeah so i talk about how we fear
the wrong things
what do we fear so most of us are
fearful of how our friends are reacting
what's happening on social media and
what's the random bit of news that we
heard
none of it is fact based that's one of
the biggest issues worry-based it's
worry-based and it's also
imagination-based so we become fiction
writers we've all watched too many
movies
now we start writing these beautiful
movies in our head we're not beautiful
scary movies in our head of what may
happen so our imagination and seneca
said it best
we suffer twice one in reality and one
in imagination
right we suffer twice and this is the
way what actually happens to us
in the story we continue to tell you
totally now there's this incredible
study in the book that i have to talk
about so they took monks and they took
non-monks and they competed against each
other
so they put this plate where you
experience heat
and so what happens is the non-monks
touch this plate now this
plate heats up gradually softly and then
at one point it gets really hot for 10
seconds then it cools down
and so what happened is that when the
non-monks touched it the
anxiety and pressure and stress in their
brain just triggered straight away even
though it wasn't that hot
it wasn't hard it was heating but it
wasn't hard to do anything major to you
but the anxiety and stress in
imagination or
in anticipation went through the roof in
the non-monks
now this is what's fascinating when the
monks touched it
they showed that it didn't feel anything
as it rose but as it got to its highest
they felt physical pain but they showed
no trigger of emotional pain because
they did not assign any emotional
element to that pain so my point with
that is you can look at the news right
now
and you can get scared straight away and
get incomplete freeze mode
feeling stuck paralyzed whatever it is
because what you're now doing is you're
creating a story
of what's going to happen and that story
and you can cause sickness in yourself
you can question just by the story so
not actually
the reality the the effects of the
disease hitting you or
something happening physically to you
totally and that story
again can be used positively so your
story
may actually be true but if it's going
to be true now you can prepare
and that shifts you away from being
scared because now you're preparing
and so the real you can be confident
because you're prepared exactly
and so we should be shifting our fear
energy
into preparation energy because what
fear does is it keeps you
locked there right we just feel stuck
i'll give you an example when you were
preparing for big games when you used to
play in the nfl right and you're playing
american football against some of the
biggest athletes in the world
it's like you can either sit there and
be scared that you're going to play this
game on the weekend
or you can prepare and your confidence
is in the preparation so when people go
how do i feel confident right now
are you preparing are you putting the
reps are you putting the rats are you
building your immunity
are you taking your vitamins are you
drinking lots of water are you drinking
lots of water are you taking the steps
that are needed to prepare for
whatever's coming
you will feel more confident that way
yeah i do feel that it's my
responsibility
to get my intentions right and so one of
my biggest visualizations that i do do
in the morning
is i so i believe that good intentions
in our life are seeds
and bad intentions are weeds and so what
is seeds and wheat
and weeds every single day he's getting
the followers
he's going to get the likes with the
seeds and weeds
every that's very snoop it's very snoop
yeah yeah different distinct seeds
yeah yeah absolutely absolutely yeah i i
like that yeah that's mate
yeah no so i was saying so what i do is
i
reflect on my intentions visually every
day
and i think about how many deals am i
taking just because they make me money
or how many videos am i making just
because they get me views or how much
stuff am i doing just for the vanity or
just for the fame or success or what i
think is
is going to be good for me like
financially economic like how the
how the default mind is set up to think
about security
as opposed to love and compassion and
wanting to change the world and wanting
to make a different place and i'm
constantly battling with the two so what
i'll do every day
is i'll reflect on my intentions i'll
reflect on the deals i've just signed
i'll reflect on
things i'm being offered and i'll
literally look at each
offer deal whatever it is each item of
thought
and i'll say is that a seed or a weed
and
if it's a weed i'll pluck it out i'll
literally visualize myself plucking out
of the
the garden of my mind and pulling it out
and taking it out
and if it's a seed then i'll water it
and i'll say okay i want that to grow
because i am doing that for the right
intention
when you can be trusted with the small
things and the small moments you get
trusted with more and more and more and
so like
it helps to just in that moment and it's
in those painful moments that you
realize how powerful you are we all know
that like you
really recognize it and and what you
said was beautiful about not rushing
through the pain because
and and you know this example's probably
been shared before but if you have a
wound and you've cut yourself it's like
you can't rush the healing
you can't rush it if you broke your arm
i mean and you've been through so many
bodily injuries
you can't rush the process it's going to
take six weeks minimum to heal broken
bar yeah
and you've got to sit through that it's
huge there's no injections you can take
there's no videos you can watch there's
nothing you can listen to
but our challenge is we try and rush
through the pain
rather than reflect through the pain we
try to rush the healing process try to
rush the healing and you can't rush
healing and
healing is meant to be slow because it
buys you time it buys you reflection it
gives you so much space
to slow down to slow down and that's
what your body is calling out from this
is our emergency like how many times
have you heard it where you slow down
you slow down and that's when you fall
ill
because guess what your body has been
trying to tell you to slow down
when you feel pain so i write about it
and think like pain
makes you pay attention yeah that's what
pain's for
pain notice this notice this look notice
me look at me it's
crazy it's like a crying baby craving
for attention when a baby's crying
you don't just go eyes crying you just
go oh yeah we'll just put it in another
room and forget about it right like you
go to and you find its needs whereas
without pain when something's painful
we're just like oh yeah i'll just forget
about it i'll escape from i'll do
something else
you have to go into that lane i'm number
people numb the pain
that's saying or whatever yeah a hundred
percent that's that's usually our
response is what can i do to numb this
work more
have sex more drink more whatever is
more whatever it is rather than let me
actually become
alert and guess what the pain just gets
higher and higher and higher and higher
because unfortunately until it really
hurts
we don't stop or you need more and more
to numb it with so true
everyone i have been reading a bit from
my friend's book evan carmichael built
to serve and i wanted to share this with
you
so according to a study by carnegie
mellon university
people with supportive spouses are more
likely to give themselves
the chance to succeed they studied 163
married couples
and found that people with supportive
spouses were more likely to take on
potentially rewarding challenges
those who accepted challenges experience
more personal growth
happiness and psychological well-being
now i can truly say that i've
experienced that in my life when i first
met my wife
i was just starting out i had never
released a video
i hadn't created any content and she was
such an important part of feeling
supported on that journey so
whether you're in a relationship whether
you're dating whether you're married or
even if you're single
being supported by friends and a strong
community is important
build to serve by evan carmichael great
book on how you can find your purpose
and also on reminding us that we can all
make a difference in the world
thanks evan you have to remind yourself
that it's okay
to feel the way you feel when you're
going for a difficult time
it's okay to feel weak it's okay to want
to cry
it's okay to feel overwhelmed just
reminding yourself that it's okay this
is my number one way
of how to find strength in difficult
times is reminding yourself
that the way you feel is okay to honor
that feeling to accept that feeling
to actually be okay with that what we
see or what we perceive to be a weakness
or what we perceive to let us down or
what we perceive
is a sign of you know instability or
insecurity
we've got to remind ourselves that when
things are tough it's okay to feel that
way there's nothing wrong with that any
difficulty i go to
i look to moments in history where
people
have endured the same pain if not more
extreme
and analyze absorb
and connect with how they got
through it i like to see what they were
thinking i like to see what they did
i like to see how they structured
themselves i like to look at how they
organized i looked like to look at who
they were speaking to i like to look at
what was going through their mind at
that time because
you've got to remember that any
challenge we're facing today
we've faced it before as a as humanity
right beyond ethnicities beyond color
race creed beyond
backgrounds beyond all walks of life as
human beings
we've been through challenges before and
we've got through them
and therefore reconnecting with how
that's been done before
is a beautiful way of learning how to
overcome current challenges so you can
either look at your past
but real wisdom lies in looking at the
past of people who made a difference you
look at people like martin luther king
you look at people like gandhi you look
at people who made
world-changing differences not
single-handedly
but influenced from a single perspective
from a single point of view
and really connecting with the powerful
moments
i've said this quote many times i've
read it many times and this quote
actually is
is unbelievable and the quote says that
they thought
they buried us they didn't know we were
seeds
right it's a mexican proverb they
thought they buried us they didn't know
we were seeds and i was thinking
these when you tell yourself that story
you start thinking much more differently
right a seed is buried too it's
incredible that the seed goes through
the same process
as anything else it's put deep
underground right
all of this mud is put on top of it it
gets rained on
it gets snowed on all these kind of
things but it knows that it's a seed
so it knows that it can grow so that
anything is possible
and it grows through and you see even
plants growing through concrete
sometimes right it's unbelievable
how much power a seed has so changing
the stories we tell ourselves we can
either look
a challenging situations as
opportunities for growth
as an opportunity to learn as an
opportunity to change be the change
or we can look at them and and really
feel down now
that that second part is okay we can
even
feel like that right but we have to
recognize it's not permanent
we've got to accept that none of our
feelings are permanent they don't need
to be permanent it's a choice
so if you need to vent vent i was saying
to someone yesterday if you need to vent
vent if you need to run
run if you need to complain complain if
you need to share how you feel do
that but recognize that those feelings
are not permanent
and it will be amazing when we realize
we are seeds right that is the most
powerful way
of finding strength in the middle of
2009
he was the software engineer that no one
wanted to hire he had
12 years of experience at yahoo but he
was rejected by facebook
and then rejected by twitter he'd been
to a great university he had a great cv
but he decided to team up with one of
his alumni members at yahoo
and started to create an app and focus
on the startup space
in five years time he sold that app for
19 billion dollars to facebook
believe it or not that was brian acton
the co-founder of whatsapp
when he was rejected from facebook he
said it was a great opportunity to
connect with some fantastic people
i look forward to life's next adventure
when he was rejected by twitter he
responded by saying
worked out it was quite a long commute
it's so
interesting to see that someone rejected
from two of the top internet companies
actually responded with humor and
actually responded with positivity
this lady was diagnosed with clinical
depression her marriage had failed and
she was jobless with a dependent child
she was on a four-hour delayed train
journey from manchester to london when
she came up with this idea and she
started to write this book about
this wizard and as she started writing
she then finished her manuscript took it
to 12
publishers and was rejected by all 12.
believe it or not that's jk rowling this
man watched his first company crumble he
was a harvard university dropout
and his first company's demo didn't even
work he went on to build microsoft his
name's
bill gates therefore failure is just a
sign that we need to widen our scope
we need to be ready and build ourselves
up for the next level
actually what we end up achieving is far
greater than what we'd envisioned for
ourselves
and this divine plan this orchestration
can't be happening without this
intervention that occurs because
if we had it our way we'd just settle we
just accept
what we thought was our goal what we
thought we were chasing
but actually i've noticed that when you
don't get that later down the line you
look back and you reflect and realize
that what you've gained is so much
greater
failures are only failures when we don't
learn from them because when we learn
from them they become
lessons and we actually extrapolate all
of these teachings and actually get
more insight into how we can improve the
way we work and
how we can actually drive with a
different energy the challenge we have
is that we only talk about people's
failures when they succeed and that's
why they become this
taboo or we feel like their failures
never happen we need to share these
stories earlier we need to bring out
these stories and experiences
on the journey so that people who are on
the journey can actually follow in those
footsteps
and that's why steve jobs said you can't
connect the dots moving forward
you only can when you're looking
backwards so the two extremes that most
of us experience
are either i have to think i'm the best
i'm the best in the world
i can crush anyone like i'm like gonna
show everyone what i'm like
or most of us experience the other
extreme which is
i'm the worst i'm the stupidest i'm the
dumbest
i'm the most worthless i'm the biggest
loser
notice how that's both ego really eager
yes
so the ego wants to be the best of the
best
or the ego wants to be the worst of the
worst the ego won't accept being in the
middle really the ego wants to feel the
deepest sense of being the lowest
and that's why victim mentality is
actually a
subsequence of ego really yeah that's
how it's explained in the bhagavad-gita
because the point is that
you can't deal with just being bad you
have to be the worst
my pain is the worst i think um jada
talked about this on your podcast where
she was like
you know i had to tell people why my
hurt was
more painful than their hurt and they
could never understand how bad it was
exactly exactly yeah that's ego as well
so you see these two sides of ego
keeping us locked away
and so the only way to get with that and
the only way to balance it and bring it
all into one
is genuine self-honesty honesty is the
best place to be the best thing about
honesty is
i'm really good at this i'm really
average of that and i'm really bad at
that
and the challenge we have with that is
most of us have no idea we just have
zero self-awareness about what we are
good at what we are better and what
we're average at so we think i'm pretty
average at everything i'm pretty good at
everything
and when i hear those answers i'm like
simple things just go and talk to people
that know you yeah what am i great at
awesome what's my superpower
what do i do differently what do you
think i do that is different than no one
else does and guess what
i guarantee you if you ask a colleague
if you ask a friend if you ask a family
member if you ask
people say different things don't say
different things but you get to learn
about yourself so
real confidence comes from knowing your
strengths
and going all in on them your confidence
does not come from
just standing up the right way or just
saying the right stuff to yourself
yeah that's and that's important i i'm a
big believer in all of that but what i'm
saying is that
that doesn't build real confidence real
confidence comes from thinking
i'm really good at this i know i can do
this and i love doing it
and really this is the most important
bit confidence comes from serving other
people
when you see the impact you have on
others and this is the biggest issue the
reason why we have such low self-esteem
today in the world is because people are
not serving others
so they don't see the profound impact
they have on others
when you put out a video or a podcast
and people tag you on instagram and they
say louis
you stop me from depression or you help
me out of
a divorce or people when they watch my
content they'll be like that stopped me
from committing suicide or whatever it
is when you see that
you get such a deep sense of self-worth
that you matter and guess what everyone
matters whether you matter to one people
or
one million people everyone matters but
if you see your impact on someone's life
you will feel such a deep sense of
self-worth and so whether you're serving
at a
uh giving out free food or whether
you're serving at a local charity place
or whether you're serving through your
work
serve serve serve because when you take
that step you you get a boost of
self-esteem
one of the most beautiful things i
learned was that serving other people
was without a doubt the most meaningful
experience of humanity
and there's this great study by michael
norton from the cambridge university
where he talks about how money can buy
happiness
if you spend it on other people and he's
done this incredible study
in all regions all across the world
where he talks about how
actually if people are given five
twenty or even a hundred dollars when
you spend it on yourself your happiness
doesn't go up or doesn't go down
but when you spend it on other people
your happiness is the opportunity to
grow by at least ten to twenty percent
so fulfillment grows when we use our
money time
energy in the service of others and when
i was working at
internships i felt like i was serving
myself and i wasn't getting an
opportunity to impact someone else's
life we've all been in that and i'm sure
you have
been in that position where you've just
made a difference in a young person's
life
or you've made a difference in someone
who doesn't have much
and you see the joy on their face and
that's what i was getting to experience
as a monk on a daily basis
albert einstein famously remarked in a
conversation with werner heisenberg
he said you know in the west we've built
a beautiful ship and in it it has
all the comforts but actually the one
thing that it doesn't have is
a compass and that's why it doesn't know
where it's going this
paradise of our times was propounded by
the dalai lama when he said we have
wider freeways but narrower viewpoints
we have
taller buildings but shorter tempers
will smith said that we spend money we
haven't earned on things we don't need
to impress people we don't like
and it's phenomenal how the same
technology that brings us close to those
are far away
takes us far away from the people that
are actually close 30 billion whatsapp
messages are sent per day but
48 of people say that they feel lonelier
in general
the paradox of our times is that we have
more
degrees but less sense more knowledge
but less judgment
more experts and less solutions it was
martin luther king who said that the
irony of our times is that
we have guided missiles but misguided
men
have you ever found it perplexing that
we've been all the way to the moon and
back
but we struggled to start a conversation
across the road or across the train and
it's amazing that bill gates
was known as the top earner in 2015 with
a
wealth of 79.2 billion but one in four
ceos claim to be struggling from
depression and do we actually
thrive off this paradox is it that this
paradox actually makes
the media interesting it's what makes
journalism interesting what makes
politics interesting it's what makes
television interesting is this
paradox actually what we feed off and
what we live off and
what we talk about and discuss in our
circles
doesn't it seem that we've tried to
clean the air but polluted our soul
we've split the atom but
not our prejudice and we're aiming for
higher incomes but
we have lower morals so i'm hearing you
ask how do we bring a change how do we
dissect this paradox that exists in our
lives and it starts by us
each of us pressing pause pressing reset
and then pressing play again
taking a moment to become more conscious
taking a moment to become more aware
taking a moment to really reflect on the
consequence the
implications of a misplaced word of an
unnecessary argument that we all know we
didn't need to have or to
speak to someone just slightly
differently in a different tone and a
different
voice and a different empathy with a
different perspective just to
really connect with people on a
different level this
thinking out loud started from albert
einstein and i'll track back to him when
he actually said that the
problems we have today can't be solved
with the same thinking we used when we
once created them so actually we need to
research
alternative teachings we need to deep
down dig into those ancient books of
wisdom we need to go
back to understanding if there's
anything written in those crease pages
of time that can actually reveal
more knowledge and more wisdom of how we
can transform our experience of light
today otherwise
this paradox means that every step
forward we take
we're taking three backwards every time
learn how to have a conversation with
yourself
like just learn how to have a
conversation with yourself
like if you don't know if i'll give it
one of the studies that i share in the
book which absolutely love uh men and
women were asked
either to be alone with their thoughts
for 15 minutes
or they could give themselves an
electric shock if they were bored
they took a shot 30 of women chose an
electric shark
and 60 of men chose an electric shock
because they didn't want to be alone
with their thoughts for 15 minutes for
15 minutes
why is that because we have not learned
to have a conversation
with ourselves or even love ourselves no
we haven't
and i think that starts with the
conversation i think you're right we
don't love ourselves but that starts
with learning to talk to yourself so
find time for you to talk to your own
mind to talk to yourself to understand
yourself to
find out how many of us when you go to a
restaurant you know whether you're going
to go back or not based on whether you
like the food
when you watch a movie you know whether
you're going to recommend it to your
friends
based on whether you liked it or not why
do we keep
visiting the same people the same places
and doing the same projects when they
don't lift us up
so many of us are not aware of the same
people that we hang around with that
bring us down
the places that don't feed us they drain
our energy and the projects that don't
light us up yeah but we keep going back
there because we don't talk to ourselves
because we don't talk to ourselves what
like i can ask you hey did you like that
restaurant
but when do we ask ourselves hey do i
like do i want to hang out with that
person does that person
want to be in this relationship we get
scared of those conversations
so i think the biggest and hardest
lesson
is that our family and our friends
will be more inspired by our example
than our education
they're going to change when they see us
change they're going to transform when
they see us genuinely transformed
they're
they're they're not fascinated by how
much you've learned and how much you
know and you can do a headstand now and
you know you can you know you can do all
these chakras and mudras and you know
all these sanskrit
words and you know like that that
doesn't move the people that have known
you
since you were young or have known you
before and that doesn't make an impact
on them what makes an impact on them is
your example and your transformation and
the amount you've changed i remember
this was really tough so someone asked a
similar question but in a
not as nicely as you did you you asked
it very respectfully
but i remember when when i was in when i
was a monk one
this question was asked to my teacher
and my teacher is actually very
compassionate but this was one of his
like heavier moments of
of like it was harsh but he was asked by
someone in the crowd they said to him
they said i'm trying so hard to
you know get my family to become
spiritual and i'm doing everything and
they don't listen to me and i'm trying
really hard and it's not working and i'm
like
doing this and i'm doing that i'm doing
this i'm teaching them this and i'm
taking this and nothing's happening
and my teacher said to them and they
were a student of his and my teacher
said to them they said he said
tolerate them as i'm tolerating you
and i was like
and so he actually said and he's super
sweet like my teacher is like 70 years
old he's been a monk for four years he's
amazing he's one of the sweetest people
in the world and he said that i was like
whoa
i was like you just got served you know
like it was it was one of those moments
and and you know he's in robes and he
says it really peacefully and everything
but
but the lesson i got from that
the lesson i got from that is that
someone's done that for us
like someone's been patiently waiting
for me to transform for me to grow
whether it's a mentor or a guide a guru
a teacher or
whatever it is like there's someone in
our life in any transformation
who's also waiting for us so part of it
is patience
patience is a huge thing you're never
gonna change
someone or make them do something and
half the time you just have to get out
of the way
the the part with patients that works is
introduce them to who they're inspired
by
don't try and be their inspiration right
and i often say that uh
to even even in parenting situations
like when parents introduce their kids
to people they're inspired by
that will help the kids more than
telling the kids to do the right thing
and i've seen that happen so often when
you look at sports as well like
even if your father was the best actor
or best sports player in the world or
your mother was the best
tennis player or performer or whatever
it is you're never impressed by your
parents
like we're really impressed by our
family when we're younger we we get
gratitude later on
but in our early days we don't have that
but we need to meet people so if you can
introduce your family to people
they're inspired by that's going to make
a huge difference and the final one like
i said at the start was just your
example
seeing you really change seeing your
behavior change your language change
your communication change
that's going to give them the greatest
confidence that you know what she's
doing is right
it works right the proof's in the
pudding the proof's in seeing you
actually
make that change scientists have known
for some time that
changing your body through actions like
smiling
sitting up straight and relaxing can
change your mental
and emotional responses when we change
our body
to sit up straight to smile to connect
with others to engage with
presence we automatically change the
responses in our mind
we allow ourselves to feel better to
think better
and to live better it's incredible to
know that simple changes
in our body language in the way that
we're sitting can
impact our emotional mood states so much
more insightful research has been done
into this space
but if you can just take a simple step
today to change your posture
to add a smile and to relax a little
you'll see
how much your mind will be at ease you
seem to be someone with great confidence
and and and wisdom at your young age
and i wonder um are there moments when
you doubt yourself when
when you think well this isn't right or
i you know
am i doing the right thing or am i am i
creating the right message today
hugely and i think that that's a
practice that i hope i never lose
because i think that's the practice that
makes you want to learn more
it makes you want to refine your message
and it also stops you from
putting out content for pressure so i
think we live in the world especially on
social media where there's such a
pressure
to put out content at volume and to keep
up with
everyone else's videos and numbers going
up and views
and for me that checking system that you
just spoke about that's what helps me
step back and go
do i really believe this or did it just
sound good for a moment
and so i hope i always keep that that
doubt i find it as a valuable tool
and i'm always going around in that
process i had that recently where
i've really i got offered book deals
from everywhere i could have ever
dreamed of after my first video went
viral
and i've resisted signing with anyone
because my personal goal is to write a
book that i actually believe in
and not write it just because it's going
to sell well and so a lot of people are
like you're taking too long
you know but i'm just like but it's a
book like people are going to pay money
and spend their time to read this book
the content has to have substance
and i have to really feel like i've
crafted something of value so i love
that i love that i doubt myself
we spend over 47 of our time
when we're browsing the internet or on
our mobile phones procrastinating
and we check our phones around 86 times
per day
put your hand up if you check it more
than that
so it's no surprise that we all face
distraction we all experience
distraction we're all plagued by
distraction but often we think that the
opposite of distraction
is focus we think that we need to become
more focused we think that if we're
focused we'll feel less distracted
we feel that if we're able to draw our
energy in a certain direction and
force ourselves to absorb in an activity
then
we won't be as distracted but this is
just not true the opposite of
distraction
is actually not focus the opposite of
distraction
is wait for it attraction let me explain
what i mean
when we're attracted to something we're
completely
fixated we're completely absorbed we're
almost
addicted and obsessed to that visual
that song what we really need to do is
increase
our attraction when we are attracted to
something
we're naturally focused we're naturally
able to be present we're naturally able
to bring our attention and our energy
to that task that project that person
when we're distracted and don't have
that attraction
we're naturally all over the place we
end up feeling lost confused
and end up procrastinating as you can
see we are procrastinating and
distracting others so now i know what
you're thinking how do you get
attracted to things that you're not
attracted to
we all have things in life that we love
to do and we all have things in life
that we have to do let's take the
example of your job
it's something that you have to do it's
something that you may not be attracted
to
when you ask yourself why do i go to my
job
maybe the answer is it pays my bills
maybe the answer is
it allows me to take care of my family
maybe you studied for years
and feel that your job at least engages
you for that
whichever one your answer is that starts
providing some
value to why you do that activity when
you know that
you recognize that you are attracted to
be there because it serves a particular
purpose
you start becoming attracted because
whenever your mind says to you i'm bored
i'm distracted i'm unfocused you say no
i'm here because it puts food on the
table i'm here
because it pays my bills and takes care
of my family
i'm here because i studied and worked
hard for this
you're able to increase your attraction
to
even the things you're totally unfocused
on
now if you found yourself distracted or
unfocused for too long
that definitely can mean that you need
to find more meaningful
fulfilling work but no matter what you
do no matter how much you chase your
passion and live your purpose
there will still be things you have to
do on a daily basis
that you don't find interesting and
naturally you will feel
unfocused and distracted for that ask
yourself this question
why am i here why am i doing this and
you'll find
the mind will start to become attracted
to that activity
task or even that person at 18 i was
really fortunate when i met a monk
and this monk was invited to speak and i
kind of just went because one of my
friends forced me to
at that time i was listening to ceos and
entrepreneurs and
business people and marketers who who i
thought that's what i was aspiring to be
like
and then i hear this monk and he
captivated me like no one had ever
captivated me before
it was like staring at the most
beautiful woman on the planet you know i
was completely fixated on him
and his message see we live in echo
chambers
we're just surrounded by the same
thinking how often do you bump into a
monk
you know it just doesn't happen you
don't have no one has a dinner party and
goes oh yeah we just invited the monk
you know from town like the local monk
like no one ever does that and so you we
meet people who are just like
us most of the time and we talk about
this in business all the time if you
want to be a billionaire spend time with
billionaires if you want to be a
millionaire spend time with millionaires
if you want to be a
tech startup spend time with you know
that's that's the common rhetoric that
we hear all the time
but what if you want to find purpose and
master the mind
there's no one better than a monk who's
mastered the mind
so so for me the first step is just
opening yourself up
to new experiences and new role models
because most of us
can't see ourselves in people
so then we try and fit ourselves into
the boxes that we do see
and and i mean there's this beautiful
quote that i've been saying it
everywhere and i wish i wrote it but i
didn't
so it's by a philosopher and writer
named cooley
and he said that today i'm not what i
think i am
i'm not what you think i am i am
what i think you think i am all right
and just let that blow your mind for a
moment
it's uh it's so powerful i'm not what i
think i am
i'm not what you think i am i am what i
think
you think i am so we live in this
perception of a perception of ourselves
hence my identity is made by what my
parents think i should be
my identity is made up by what my
college or university
thinks i should achieve while you're
living in that bubble in that echo
chamber
getting to what you really want to do is
impossible
because maybe that just doesn't fit and
i think so many people feel that way
today
that they don't fit into the current
education system they don't fit with the
three or four or five careers that
you're taught exist
so that process of self-excavation and
actualization
first requires being exposed you can't
be what you can't see
if i never saw a monk i would never have
wanted to be a monk
if i never meet a billionaire i wouldn't
want to be one because i wouldn't know
what that feels like i don't know what
it looks like i don't know what it takes
and i think that's the biggest challenge
of our society that we're not exposed so
that's the first step
being exposed to unique experiences and
role models
second step is finding that experience
or role model that you're passionate
about and exactly like you said
taking it seriously shadow them network
with them spend time with them
observe them even from afar it takes
that observation
being addicted to observing that
person's lifestyle
and then the third step is going yes or
no
does that work for me not everyone who's
going to go off and become a monk is
going to feel like the way i did and
that's cool
but not everyone is going to go and
follow and shadow a billionaire and go
that's exactly the lifestyle i want they
may want the result
but do they want the hard work that goes
with it and so for me that's the third
step
it's observing focusing shadowing
getting as close to the process of that
individual
and then going yes or no do i want that
process
not do i want the result everyone wants
to be that monk who's fully enlightened
you know can walk through has an
incredible aura
that people just gravitate towards but
when you realize he has to wake up at 2
a.m every day and sleeps about four to
six hours you're like ah you know i
don't want to do it
that doesn't sound like me the second
thing we usually get wrong
is that we don't believe in what we're
sharing i've realized that i've grown
much more confident about speaking in
front of people and even in front of you
right now on video because i talk about
stuff that's really meaningful to me
that's really purposeful to me
i only choose to share messages that
truly resonate with my heart and my head
and my intelligence and things that i've
immersed myself in for a number of years
everything i'm sharing these stories
these ideas they aren't just made up to
sound good these are things that i
really truly try and live and practice
and embody in my own
day-to-day life and therefore if you
don't really believe in what you're
speaking about if you don't really
understand it if you haven't tried to
live it then you're always going to
struggle trying to articulate it and
even if you get away with articulating
something perfectly that you don't
believe in you'll feel empty inside and
that's why
sales roles usually end up making people
feel quite empty because they're selling
stuff and products that they don't think
will change your life
make sure if you're trying to
communicate a message for your brand
if you're trying to sell a product if
you're sharing insights and ideas they
have to be things that genuinely connect
with you internally this this feels
weird are you
are you sure this is legal there are
sometimes when i'm
with a social media person who says
something really useful for my roots and
there's someone comes around with roots
and they say something else and
there's a great story actually about
when the prime minister of india modi
he visited facebook and mark zuckerberg
interviewed him at facebook at the
headquarters
and mark zuckerberg told his story he
said that when he was struggling with
the direction of facebook in 2009
he went up to his mentor to ask a
question
now smart zuckerberg's mentor happened
to be steve jobs and so he went up to
steve jobs and he said steve i'm
struggling with the direction of
facebook what do i do
and at that time you know i mean steve
jobs
is steve jobs he could have said
anything and it would have made sense
but
you know he could have said go and meet
a venture capitalist he could have said
go and be an investor he could have said
go and meet a tech company he could have
said i'll tell you what to do
instead he said i think you need to go
to india
and spend some time in an ashram a
monastery in india with monks
he goes when you do that you'll find the
answer of what you want to do
and to me that is exactly why the people
that are most successful in this world
are successful
because they surround themselves with
people who have
differing beliefs and mit did a research
study on this they found that people who
are more innovative and creative in an
organization
new people who didn't know each other so
when you know people who all know each
other
you end up with the same answer the same
belief and confirmation bias exists
and you just keep building that echo
chamber whereas if you've got two people
who don't agree and you get a checking
system
then you can trust your gut and go with
what you believe so i think
i try and move away from having people
around me and it's not just yes men
or yes women it's about it's not just
about that it's about building a circle
of people
like you said that want different things
for you
and knowing what they want for you so
when i'm with my mom all my mom cares
about is my health
right my mom does not care how
successful i am how many videos happen
how many people i help even that
and my mom will get over there she's
like how's your health are you taking
care of yourself are you sleeping well
are you eating well like that's my mom
and it's like if i go and i measure
everything most of that that's wrong but
if i know that that's what my mom wants
for me that's beautiful
that's what i get from her and she'll
take care of that and same you know
everyone plays a different role in your
life
don't expect everyone to play the role
you want and don't expect everyone to
play the same role
recognize that everyone's playing their
role in your life and let them play it
that's what makes a good movie if
everyone played the same role in a movie
would be boring very boring
i'd like you to fast forward to 70 80
90 years old right fast forward in your
mind
to that age 70 80 90 100 110 if you're
really optimistic whichever one it is
and i'd like you to write down what will
be the things that you'll regret
that you didn't do imagine you're that
age
ask yourself the question what will i
regret that i didn't do not what you did
do but what you didn't do
write it down make a long wrist right
now get a pen and paper out and write it
down don't do it on your phone don't do
it on your laptop
actually get a pen and paper and write
down your answers what will be the
things that you regret that you didn't
do
right really think about it would it be
you know learning a new language will it
be
moving home will it be telling someone
you love them what will it be what would
have been
write it down right now now the
incredible thing about this question is
that
you're using the future to empower the
past whatever answer you have
in that question whatever your answer is
you can do it right now today starting
today because you're not that age
and if you're even if you're 64 and
you're tuning in 70 80 90 you're still
there right it's still possible
you can start doing that right now it's
empowering the present with the future
there is nothing stopping you from
making it happen right now
you don't have to feel that way when
you're 70 you don't have to feel that
way when you're 18. you never
ever have to feel that way if you start
doing it right now and you can do it
right now
even if it feels impossible you can
start working on it right now you can
start trying right now you can start
making plans right now
because you're not there yet and this is
where you start this is where you start
making it happen it's
all in the now so how do i find my
passion my
simple model which is the dharma model
it also dharma means
eternal duty in the vedic tradition it's
very similar to what ikigai is being
spoken about today
which is a japanese version of reason
for being
why do we live where is meaning coming
from and it talks about an intersect of
four
areas what am i good at what do i love
what does the world need and how do i
get paid for it
to me those four help you unlock your
passion when you find the intersect
across all of those four
you're making your passion your purpose
you'll unlock your passion you'll find
your purpose
this is path one there's two paths path
one i find my skill set
and i engage it to help other people and
become better at it
so i'm becoming better at what i'm good
at and i'm using it to help other people
because i'm aware of what i'm quite good
at and i know what what knowledge i have
what skills i have i have some
self-awareness
the other path that people often miss is
actually i just start serving people i
just start helping people
and i start to notice what i enjoy about
that and what i'm good at helping people
with
so that's gandhi's part gandhi said that
you find yourself when you lose yourself
in the service of others
so for me those are the two paths of how
do i find my passion
and finding the intersect between those
four areas in life
you're either a passenger or a pilot
you've got that choice
this is one of the biggest choices
you'll ever make
are you defining what direction you're
moving in
or are you letting other people make the
biggest decisions of where you're going
see at first it's more comfortable being
the passenger you sit back
relax have people serve you it feels
easier it feels more natural but then as
time goes by
you look outside the window and you
realize you've ended up somewhere that
you didn't want to be
then you start blaming people around you
blaming people who made those decisions
for you blaming people who should take
responsibility
for where you've ended up sometimes you
feel lost confused
and wonder how you ever got there and in
that moment at that time you've got this
important choice to make you can either
switch seats
grab hold of the steering wheel and
start guiding your life
or remain a passenger you can't be both
which one are you how many of you have a
crazy
dream or a crazy goal i want you to
write out in the comments section
what is your crazy dream the dream that
keeps you up at night
is the real dream you should be chasing
but to chase that dream
to find that dream to make that dream a
reality you need a strategy
right a dream without a plan is just a
wish tony robbins said that
right a dream without a plan is just a
wish right without a strategy without
a guiding philosophy without guiding
principles without actually creating a
clear plan
i used to have this economics teacher
and i want you to think back to school
as well
maybe you had one i remember this
economics teacher he walked in
to the classroom and the first thing
that he wrote on the board he didn't
even tell us his name
we didn't even know who he was and he
turned up he went inside the classroom
and he wrote on the board he said
failing
to prepare is preparing to fail and all
of us just burst out laughing this guy
hadn't even told us his name yet
but on the board he wrote failing to
prepare is preparing to
fail and now when i look back at that
and as i grew up and
hopefully became a bit more mature than
i was in high school
i remember thinking about that statement
and thinking how true is that
that when you're not prepared for
something you miss out on unbelievable
opportunities
now i'm not saying good things don't
happen spontaneously sometimes things
happen
by chance randomly etc with a reason but
when you're prepared you can capitalize
on things
in a huge huge way play to your own
element don't try and perform someone
else's expertly
so in modern terminology how would i say
that is
don't waste your time steve jobs don't
waste your time trying to live someone
else's life
you know don't be trapped by dogma focus
in on your own strengths your own
element what you have to offer
don't get lost in trying to become like
someone else or
pretend to be someone else there's a
beautiful
one of my favorite quotes by einstein
and then steve jobs again einstein said
if you judge a fish by its ability to
climb a tree that will spend its whole
life believing that it's stupid
and too many of us are fish trying to
climb a tree
too many of us are monkeys being taught
how to swim too many of us are lions
being taught to live like cats
we're not getting to live in our element
so my second piece of advice is
live in that element that you've
naturally been given
don't try adopt another you know we've
all got a special genius inside of us
it was steve wozniak and steve jobs this
conversation
steve wozniak looked steve wozniak for
those who don't know is the tech guy
behind apple
he practically invented the technology
and the software and everything
so steve wozniak looked at steve jobs
and he says this is in walter isaacson's
biography of steve jobs steve wozniak
wasn't yet looks at steve jobs and he
says what do you even do
he said you're not a coder you're not a
designer you're not a marketer and
you're not an engineer
what do you even do imagine challenging
steve jobs
and steve jobs replies he says he says
musicians play their instruments
i play the orchestra that is the most
deep
understanding of one's role in life and
not getting lost in other people's
identities and perceptions of you
steve jobs knew that he wasn't a
marketer he wasn't an engineer he wasn't
a coder
so he hired all of those but he played
the orchestra he brought it all together
and that's when you when you find
confidence in your own role you won't be
envious of anyone else
so that's the second one what happens in
society is that we're clouded by
the noise the noise of family
expectations the noise of our parents i
grew up in a family where you could
either be a doctor
a lawyer or a failure those were my
three options anything else would just
count me as a failure right i'm standing
up here
in front of you all as a failure we
focus so much on life in what we want to
be
as opposed to who we want to be we've
always been told that life and jobs and
careers are like boxes and containers
there's only a finite number of options
you can decide right now that i don't
want to be defined by this box i don't
want to be defined by this container i
don't want to feel that
if only i live in this container then
i'll be able to be successful
most of us just throw ourselves into the
deep end
and then try swim and figure it out
right monk life actually
begins at like five years old like the
training of monk life is ultimately
training in self-actualization and
self-awareness
it's meant to start when you're five the
problem is we all went to normal schools
that try to put stuff in us rather than
take stuff out of us it's crazy you talk
about this
right right right like you you know you
were told at school that you weren't
very good and you weren't going to
english and now you have a new york
times bestseller right yeah and it and
it's like but
no one noticed that potential inside you
no one noticed that
oh lewis was really creative right and
you're not the only person there's so
many people who feel like that
so the modern schooling system didn't
extrapolate your
self-actualization your element and just
try to put maths
english science inside so the point is
that you're trying to get to
such a strong foundation that when you
interact in the world
you're going with a sense of strength
fuel energy to make a difference
rather than going into the world and
then going oh my god where am i trying
to figure it out
and i find what happens today is that
when you don't we all know this we i
mean self-love has become such a big
thing now
when people don't figure out yeah it's
like a huge now
but but my point is that if you don't
start at a place
where you have self-awareness
self-actualization
you have figured out what works for you
what your strengths are
how you want to be in an environment
when you walk out there
most of us just pretend to be someone
else most of us get lost most of us
get carried away yeah so my point is
strengthen yourself grow yourself and
then of course interact with the world
steve jobs said that you should never
start a company with the goal of getting
rich it should be about starting a
company to make something you believe in
we should dream to make a difference
break down
boundaries build beyond borders and
ignite ideas to
innovate incessantly and create for
people what they can
never conjure up themselves henry ford
said that if i had asked people what
they wanted they would have said faster
horses and that's the beauty of
going beyond wanting money and going
beyond wanting fame
going beyond wanting power that you
actually craft something that evolves
people's daily lives that
you actually create something that
enhances someone's
human experience people respond to
people who want to do more than just
gain for themselves we're attracted by
selflessness we're
attracted by renunciation we're
attracted by the quality
of when people want to give rather than
take when they want to share rather than
keep and
when they want to do and serve rather
than just hold
steve jobs said being the richest man in
the cemetery doesn't matter to me
what matters to me is going to sleep
feeling like we've done something
wonderful
i just really have had to build up rules
around my social media use
you have so my rule is never look at the
phone first thing in the morning
oh my gosh i am really trying this is my
biggest one
i think if we did this we would conquer
our lives
i have now not looked at instagram first
thing in the morning i just look at like
the text the email okay we're good
i that's good yep that's huge it is for
me
that's huge at one point i actually used
to put my phone and my laptop locked in
my car downstairs
well because that was the only way i
could truly convince myself
not to look at my phone and i think we
have to go to that extent sometimes or
that extremity to really push ourselves
out of it so i don't look at my phone
until i go down to the gym which is two
hours after i meditate and wake up and
everything so i try and avoid looking at
my
phone for those first two hours and i
find what that does is it gives your
mind time to warm up
you don't start your mind on someone
else's reactive schedule right when you
wake up and you look at that email and
you look at that notification you're now
thinking about everything everyone wants
you to do
not what you want to do right you're not
thinking about who you want to be or
what you want to achieve you're thinking
about oh mary wants me to get that right
you know julie wants me to do that right
like whatever it is like you start
thinking about everyone else's schedule
and then the third thing that happens is
and i've said this before but i think
it's really powerful
when you think about it i think about
this in the morning it really stops me
none of us and i mean literally none of
us would let a hundred people
walk into our bedroom first thing in the
morning that's true
ever before doing your hair before you
do maybe your makeup getting
clothes on having a shower you would
never do that but we let a hundred
notifications enter our mind
that's literally try trying to shake our
consciousness awake right it's like
really trying to wake your mind up
you're expecting your mind
going from zero to 60 miles per hour in
five seconds when you open up instagram
or whatsapp or emails
and it's so much pressure on our minds
that's really all it is it's
pressure and stress for your mind to
have to wake up and warm up
way quicker than our bodies the pressure
of finding your purpose is crazy will
stop you from finding your purpose
literally the pressure is so heavy and
that's why it's not about finding that
it's just starting with the basics
what am i good at and i talk about it i
break down dharma in here and i talk
about what are your passion
what is your expertise what is your
compassion
because that's really important what is
your compassion for the world like
what problem do you want to solve i
often people will say there's so many
things i could do there's so many things
i'm like
my question is not what causes you the
greatest joy sometimes my question is
what is what causes you the greatest
pain mm-hmm
make that your purpose make that your
purpose if you don't know what your joy
is you definitely know what your pain is
in the world and so for me go serve that
thing 100
so for me the greatest pain i see in the
world
is people not reaching their potential
that
is that causes me more pain because i
believe that there is someone out there
who is stacking shelves who has the cure
to cancer right there is someone out
there
or he's a talented singer he's a
talented singer there is someone out
there who's not living to their
potential
and i think we're better people we're
better partners and we're better parents
when we live to our potential so that's
what i'm trying to solve and i'm not
saying that's the biggest thing sure the
same is my thing
how do you help people
develop their strengths and recognize
what their strengths are in the first
place
and calm that monkey mind so that they
can see clearly
this is this is why i love tom you're
just amazing tommy you're literally
explaining my book for me i'm just like
this is like the biggest masterclass of
the book it's great uh
no and you're spot on that the monkey
mind
is what we all experience every day so
the monkey mind is jumping from branch
to branch
it doesn't want to focus on the root of
the issue it wants to find the next
banana
it wants to find the next excuse it
wants to find the next
instant gratification right that's the
monkey mind
and so the monkey mind is never going to
help you focus on your strengths
and the reason going back to one of the
earlier questions you ask the reason why
we struggle to find our passion
is because the world is constantly
pushed us away from our strengths
we've constantly told to focus on your
weaknesses oh you've got three a's and a
d
you should be working on that d let's
get that up to an a
right i remember in my school they
had this excruciating exercise where
you'd be ranked
1 to 180 on every subject every year
and they'd send the list home to your
parents so there were 180 students in my
year
group and every subject art math english
science geography history you name it
you were ranked 1 to 180
in every subject based on your test
results and scores
and that was like painful when my
parents received that
and the crazy thing was i would always
outperform
always in art design philosophy and
economics
i was in english i was always in the top
half
if not in the top quarter if not in the
top five
right of my whole year group and stuff
like science and geography
and math i was kind of like in the
middle
and and towards the bottom end of my
year now granted i went to a competitive
school so i was still okay at those
things
but the interesting thing was that my
parents and my friends parents
would never look at what you came one or
two or three in
they'd be looking at the things you came
90 100 110 in
and so we've all been programmed to say
oh your strengths are they're fine
they're good the way they are but why
are you not performing at this
and so the one way to know your
strengths
is to ask yourself what do you do
that you feel the most confidence doing
and it could be something as simple as
i'm great at organizing birthday parties
it could be like that may be your skill
right that might be your strength or it
may be something like
i'm really good at putting on makeup or
it could be that i have a great sense of
fashion
it could be any of those things and if
you don't know it yet
you can also do an exercise where you
sit down with a colleague a family
member and a friend
because you need people from all areas
of your life and you ask them what do
you think i
do that i excel in that i stand out in
or if you could trust me to do one thing
in your life for you what would that one
thing be
and when you ask that to people in a
reflective way really asking for that
presence
you might be surprised by what they say
and that's such a powerful question to
ask because someone may actually say
something like to you
like jay i think your greatest strength
is
just knowing what to say to me when i
most need it
and you may think well that's not a
strength you can do anything with
but it is it is a strength that you can
do a lot with
if you are okay with accepting that of
course i want someone to say to me
oh jay you're you're an athlete like
cristiano ronaldo and
you could play football and get the
ballon d'or and win all these trips but
that's not my reality
and so i feel that that's the place that
i would start with strengths
and there was a great study done on
the healthy wealthy and wisest people in
the world
and they were asked if you could invest
in what you're good at
your average at or what you're bad at
where would you put your money and so if
you take a hundred percent how would you
divide that as a ratio
and if you ask this i want everyone
who's listening and watching at home
right now to do this exercise
and you may write down 33 33 33 you may
write down
40 40 20 you may write down 10 1080
whatever you write down
the most healthy wealthy wisest
successful people on the planet
will say theirs is a hundred zero zero
or eighty
ten ten they go all in on their
strengths
because they know that if they go all in
on their strengths they can become
exceptional at it
now here's the caveat when it comes to
your hard skills
focus on your strengths but when it
comes to your soft skills
focus on your weaknesses now you got to
tell me which is which yeah so hard
skills
are things like excel math uh
product design using a video camera
uh script writing speaking these are all
hard skills in the sense that they're
very clearly defined very tangible
you can really measure them it's almost
like a skill that's measurable
your soft skills are like emotional
intelligence
listening compassion empathy these are
all soft skills
or considered soft skills and those are
where you focus on your weaknesses
because they can actually end up
tripping you up
while you're trying to become the best
at doing the hard skill
so you may be the best videographer in
the world but if you don't know how to
listen to your community
and your team then no one's going to
want to work with you
and so to me that's the missing link
that we're actually the other way around
we put all our emphasis on getting
better
at our weaknesses and our hard skills
and we think that because we're
empathetic and good people that that
will be enough
and it doesn't work that way fred smith
was an undergraduate at yale university
in 1965.
as part of his coursework he wrote an
economics paper exploring the
transportation of goods in the united
states
it's how things get delivered to you and
me he found that shippers were
transporting large packages
and items either via truck or through
passenger airplanes he thought he had a
more efficient method
he wrote a last-minute paper as you do
about how a company
transporting small items via a plane
would be a much better business model
because he was rushed he never really
got around to explaining in the paper
how that company would run and he ended
up getting a c
the funny thing is he still didn't give
up and in 1971
he actually launched the company he was
speaking about but within three years of
founding the company
federal express as it was called was
actually on the verge of bankruptcy they
were losing over a million
a month that was because of rising fuel
costs competitors in the same market
and at its zenith it was only worth
about five thousand dollars
smith even made a final pitch to general
dynamics hoping for more funding and it
was rejected
most people at this point probably would
have just shut down rejection the great
c losing a million a month but fred
smith had different ideas
smith actually ended up flying to las
vegas that weekend with
all of what the company had the five
thousand dollars the monday morning
after
the company had thirty two thousand
dollars thanks to his blackjack skills
that money made it possible to cover
fuel costs for just
a few days more soon after the company
was able to raise significant
funds he went around to multiple places
to find sponsors
investors people that believed in what
he was trying to achieve as a service
the amazing thing is that he was
creating a company that we all know
today it's called fedex it now operates
in over 220
countries and has an annual revenue of
over 45
billion dollars the interesting lesson
that we can learn here
is that there were countless occasions
in fred smith's life
where he could have said that's it it's
not working for me he could have stopped
when he got that c for the paper he
could have stopped when he was losing a
million a month he could have even
stopped when he finally only had enough
to just
last a few more days but he believed in
his vision he had belief
he had conviction about his idea and the
process and the service that he was
creating
and that's the lesson here if you really
want to achieve something
you'll find a way and if you don't
you'll find excuses
i think mark zuckerberg said it
brilliantly at harvard he was saying
that finding your purpose
isn't enough you have to help other
people find theirs and i know you're
passionate about this
whatever that definition is but it has
to lead
everyone so if i'm whether i meet a
celebrity an entrepreneur
or whether i meet someone who's starting
out i'm always asking them the question
how can you use what you have to make a
difference in the life of other people
yeah because if you start there
everything else will work out but if
you're starting from the point of what
am i going to get
then you're always going to feel
disconnected and i see that i
see people who live like that and feel
pain in their lives every day i see that
it's not like some
conceptual philosophy we see it i see
people who are
only in it for themselves and they feel
disconnected dissatisfied every single
day
and then you see the other extreme where
people are just trying to give too much
more than they even have themselves and
they also feel disconnected
and again nothing at all they have
nothing at all right so we know
again attachment and aversion two sides
of the same coin
so we want to be in that dynamic balance
of growth but always to give
yeah so i always think how can i go
three steps deeper
so that i can move three steps forward
so i can give three times as much
right it's all that's always my
mentality how do i go deeper
to go more forward to give more yeah and
if i can get those
three in action for that reason see it's
all about the reasoning
you can do anything you like but it's
why are you doing it
right now it's incredible that we root
for underdogs
it's incredible that we want underdogs
to win why because we're used to wanting
our team to win
we're used to wanting the best to win
we're used to wanting to associate
ourselves with people who are successful
right we never go oh yeah i know someone
who plays for that really bad team like
we don't say that right we say things
like oh i know someone who plays with
that really good team i know someone who
was
mvp i know someone who's the son or the
daughter of the mvp
we try and associate or link ourselves
to success
and when we do that it in turn makes us
feel more successful
it's one of the reasons why when your
team wins you say we won
right you say we won but when someone
asks you oh how did your team do and if
they lost that day you say
they lost you rarely say we lost it's
incredible
how psychologically we distance
ourselves from
failure and we closen or liken ourselves
to success
but the exception to that rule is the
underdog
we all get excited by underdogs we all
get motivated by underdogs
we feel completely enamored by the story
of
the underdog prashan underdogs are just
simple-minded they don't have
expectations
and don't have anything to prove to
anybody and prashant you've just hit the
nail on the head
that's the principle i'm trying to get
across actually we should play like
champions
and train like underdogs why because the
underdog
works in a way not worrying about what
anybody else
thinks or believes that gives you
an edge it gives you a phenomenal
advantage when you're
actually worried about what will people
say when you're not concerned
by am i going to fail am i going to look
worse
is what i'm doing not going to succeed
as an underdog you don't let those
things cloud your mind you can
focus in on the task at hand see when we
become successful even as underdogs if
we've risen to success
the biggest enemy of that success
the biggest achilles heel the biggest
thing that can trip us up
is not reconnecting to that feeling of
an underdog so no matter how much
success you've achieved
no matter where you are always remind
yourself the mindset of an underdog
is the mindset that nurtures talent that
nurtures success
that harnesses your true potential my
daily practice
is to refine my intention the the
biggest weeds that we all get is on our
intention
so when i say intention i mean my
current intention
is to use everything i've been given
everything that i have
in the service of others so i want to
use
the following that i have to help people
i want to use the money that i have to
help people i want to use the network
that i have to help people
but every day that intention which is a
beautiful little
plant that's growing gets weeds around
it
no do it for the money right do it for
the fact
just do it for the fame do it for the
followers do it for this all these weeds
are like going around
my real intention every day every day
that's a weed
a weed is the intention that you don't
want and the problem is
sometimes you've let it grow so much the
weed
looks like the plant right the weed
looks like
your intention and you start believing
it's the same thing
so for me my daily practice is going
back in reflecting on what is my voice
right now in my head what am i saying to
myself
and i'm hearing make that deal it makes
a lot of money do this do that do this
more followers fame all that stuff and
i'm cutting it down i'm cutting that
weed every day
and you've got to do it every day
because the more you're surrounded by
that energy
right the more it's going to keep
creeping in like a creeper weed right
so for me my three e's are element
environment and energy everyone has an
element that they thrive in if you take
someone out of it their element they
won't be the same
a modern day example would be michael
jordan he was incredible at basketball
he took him out of basketball put him in
the baseball no one remembers his career
we're talking about one of the best
athletes of all time your environment
is the environment around you you can
take a fish out of water and give it a
beautiful mansion
and a bentley and all the money in the
world but it will die
and that's what we are like our
environment everyone needs an
environment which they thrive
which we have to craft your boss if
you're at work is never going to ask you
hey
what environment do you succeed in right
like that never happens
so we have to create an environment
where we thrive
and then finally it's energy we some of
us love high energy environments high
pressure
some of us succeed in low energy
environments and low pressure
figuring out your energy and the
frequency on which you operate
best will help you thrive as well so for
me those are the three e's
to really create a thriving environment
know your element know your
environment and know your energy and so
at
all times if i see anything going wrong
i'm going is my element out of alignment
is my environment out of alignment or is
my energy out of alignment
and that's a great three question test
you can do to yourself when you don't
think things are going right
and all you have to do is bring that
back into alignment
we usually don't practice enough i
realize that if you
really want to be good at something you
have to invest in it with all your life
you have to become
addicted and absorbed to improvement and
growth that means being open to feedback
that means being open to what the
experts have to say about you it means
not being attached to your ego
and how you feel about yourself but
opening up yourself to an
expert group of people to give you
insights on how you can grow
evolve and perform at a higher rate and
link to that
is practice practice practice it's
literally impossible to do something
perfectly the first time you do it the
more you do it the better you
get and we think practice is a cliche
that we hear all the time
but actually it's that truth it's so
simple you might miss it
did i miss something here this man began
singing and playing the guitar at age
four his parents didn't want him to
watch too much television
he was banned from playing video games
but he had a lot of books
about art he didn't enjoy school and was
even bullied
at age 15. a year later he decided to
quit school
and follow his dreams of making in the
music industry
now things didn't go as planned he ended
up homeless
sleeping often on trains just to get by
this lasted for around three years where
he had nowhere to live
he spent multiple nights and days
performing to small groups
often without even eating to his
surprise
some of his tracks went viral on itunes
even reaching the number two
spot on the itunes chart by the end of
the year
his album had sold 801 000 copies
making it the eighth best-selling album
of the year
his latest song was one of the most
listened to
worldwide his name ed sheeran
today he's mentored by elton john paul
mccartney says that he's a fan
he's even written songs for taylor swift
one direction and many many more
ed's story teaches us that there's no
such thing as an overnight success
he was so shocked and surprised when his
album went viral online
but when you look at the struggle before
that you see the pain
he had to go through often we only view
people's
success as what we see in their
highlight reel
and we forget what they actually had to
go through to get to that stage
and that's why the next time you see
someone that you think is successful
don't focus on what they're doing now
focus on what they did
to get them what are people not
understanding about
video okay what are they not
understanding about how powerful it is
for their business
their brand and ultimately their message
to impact people it's always that same
question what's the roi on social media
right what's the roi now the funny thing
is your business work and service my
business work and service literally
lives off of social media so there's
obviously an roi
but the problem is we live in a world
where we want everything to be
measurable
and there's a beautiful einstein quote
that says not everything that counts can
be counted
and not everything that you can count
counts right and we live in this world
where everything needs to be measured
like oh that video has a million views
how many sales did you get through that
but it's like life doesn't work like
that there's a load of adverts and
billboards on the street
that the biggest brands pay for that
don't convert into direct sales
do you think that coca-cola looks at the
billboard out there and goes how many
people
saw that advert today and how many
people bought a coca-cola because of
that advert
they don't have that number it doesn't
exist and they're one of the biggest
brands in the world but they still do it
so social media video is just a new
billboard and the biggest brands know
that the more you see it like i mean
this is funny i saw this today i saw a
big billboard outside of my hotel
that has all the jenners and the
kardashians wearing their kelvins have
you seen it yeah right i saw it straight
away this morning
then i saw it on instagram and then i
swear everywhere so already
i've seen it in three places now i don't
need women's calvin
underwear but the point is that i've
seen it in a million places
so anyone who's not using video hasn't
understood
that more people are going to see video
than anything else
and not just that video is so much
better than a billboard you can say so
much
more right so for me it's just a lack of
seeing opportunity
there's a there's a great i think this
is a old tale it's not true
but but it's told that when nike first
went to
india they went there and it's not nike
it's any any sneaker brand it's it's a
nice story and
when they first went to india they saw
everyone was barefoot
so the first reporter came back and said
oh there's no market there because no
one wears trainers
and then the second reporter went then
he said oh no one wears shoes and then
he came back and says we've got a huge
market out there
right and it's the way you see it that
someone saw no one wearing shoes there's
no mark here but another person saw
everyone not wearing shoes as a market
right and that's what video is that you
can sit here and debate the roi on video
for as long as you want
but the truth is every major brand has
invested
in a front window that may not translate
to direct sales or work or whatever it
is
right but it does do you think every
brand should be using video every brand
should be using video i'm almost 30
and i don't feel like i've accomplished
anything in life i made a promise to
myself while i was at university
that i would get a job that excites me
every morning but right now i'm afraid
i'm not going in that direction that
note was written by a young person
and when i read it my heart sank i felt
that way because i know so many people
that are in that exact position i
remember when i decided to trade my nine
to five for a 24
7 it was because i wanted to do
something that was meaningful
every day i wanted to do something that
was purposeful and fulfilling from the
moment i woke up to the moment i went to
sleep
the one thing i didn't know before i
started is how achievable that was
but also what it required when i
transitioned from my nine to five or
actually my nine to nine
to a 24 7 i realized that i was going to
have to work harder
smarter and faster and that step was
full of fear full of anxiety
full of insecurity full of questions
like what will happen if it doesn't work
what will people say should i just have
stayed where i was
i went through all of those emotions all
at the same time
and then something came to me i wrote
down the various options that i had in
life at the time
and i wrote a word above them that i
believe summarized the experience
or the result of what i thought that
would give me some of them said ego
because i thought those career paths
would give me a boost to my ego
some said security because there were
certain roles or jobs i could take that
would provide a certain level of
financial security and then one path
said the word love because i knew if i
did that that i would love every moment
even if it was truly challenging and
sometimes really difficult to deal with
and that's why i'm here today making
this video speaking to all of you
because i chose the path that had the
word
love above it try that exercise try that
activity out to try and differentiate
the motive the intention
behind what you're choosing and
selecting in life now just because you
choose the word love doesn't mean that
everything is going to be smooth sailing
and that you're going to be successful
it's going to have its own ups and downs
and that's why wherever you go with your
heart take your head with you
what's the impact that you want to have
on the world i think you've
you've said it so beautifully so many
times and shared my vision which is
wonderful and
it's wonderful to know that we share the
same thing it's making wisdom go viral
there's an incredible study in 2017 that
said the most
successful people in the world healthy
wealthy and wise choose
education over entertainment
the impact i want to have from the world
is i want to transform and revolutionize
the entertainment industry
so that it becomes educational without
anyone knowing
so it's still completely entertaining
it's still like watching netflix
but you're learning about human behavior
the mind neuroscience and everything
without even knowing you are to me
that's the greatest win
that we can have for our society how
many people are going to quit watching
netflix and reading a book every night i
don't know
but if we can make that book come to
life on netflix that's going to change
the world
because that's what people are going to
consume so for so long
media has been used to numb people to to
switch people off if we can use it to
excite
elevate and enlighten people not by
just not by like the cheesy way of like
oh let's follow someone through their
journey of
enlightenment it's not like that kind of
stuff i mean like really entertaining
programming
where you can learn by being entertained
at the same time if i can do that
by changing the most powerful industry
in the world
then i will feel that i've had some some
whatever an impact
because that way i think we'll reach the
world without having to get everyone to
change their habits too much
uh my thing is how do we meet people
where they are
and and really deliver a message and a
powerful
expression of love and to me that's the
highest form of compassion the highest
form of empathy
love and compassion is to meet people
where they already are
rather than expecting them to change for
me i usually write down
each option that i have in life and i
think we all have different options in
life and then i'll place a word above it
that feels like the right emotion so
either
it can be fame i could be doing
something just because of ego and fame
it could be doing something i've loved
if we're doing something for money and
stability i could be doing something for
uh for inspiration and passion so i try
and
define why it's defining that why that
intention behind it like why would i
take that extra flight off to singapore
oh because i'm gonna make x amount of
money right like and literally when you
look at your life
like that yeah yeah there you go and
then i'd be like okay that's a weed now
can i transform it into a seed is there
a way for me to make it more intentional
purposeful and conscious
if i can that's amazing i'll do that but
if i can't i need to stop
taking things like that into my life and
now i understand for anyone listening
there are times in our life where money
has to be the motivator because we need
security we need stability
but when you do it intentionally at
least then you don't expect that thing
to bring you the greatest happiness
because you know what purpose it's
serving in your life so i know a lot of
people who'd love to quit their jobs and
live their passion
but i'm like no but you know why if you
know why you're doing the job you're
doing
you won't expect it to make you happy
you know what it serves excellent
in shamanism we have this viewpoint that
spirituality
is not separate from life it's it means
as someone who's spiritual
even if they don't meditate or work with
crystals or do any of these things it
means they're willing to evolve
i want to know what your thought is
about that yeah i completely agree
i think that's beautiful and completely
aligns with me i don't think
see we look at everything about oh what
can i learn
and actually half of learning in my
opinion is really unlearning
everyone already has the answer inside
of them you're not really learning
anything new you're just trying to get
rid of all the bad lessons you learned
and everyone has that so it's not so
much about like oh is this person going
from here to here
it's not really that it's like it's
someone going from here to here and
for me one of the ways i've always
thought about is you can't take the
world
further than where you visited
internally so
for me every person that we're meeting
already has that journey right there
and all you're asking them to do is look
inwards as opposed to outward so no i i
completely agree with you and i think
that's a beautiful point that you've
shared
and i think it's something nice for us
to know so we don't judge and label
people
we don't walk around think oh those are
spiritual people those are not spiritual
people
because yeah we're all yeah
we're all spiritual people and it's just
that some are covered it's like the
sun's always out
but often it's covered with the clouds
rarely here a bit more lately
but some it's the sun is always out it's
just getting covered by the clouds and
that's us
we've just been covered and we get
covered by those clouds and they cloud
our
identity they cloud our perception and
so all we're doing for ourselves and
others is clearing out the clouds
and the more we do that for ourselves
the more we can do it for others and the
more we do it for others the more we do
it for ourselves
in 2016 i moved out to new york so just
let me paint a picture of 2016.
i moved three jobs i got married
wow i moved country
and i just just started a whole new life
like my life just transformed so we went
to all of that with my wife
in one year and by the way all of that
was surprises the job chains were
surprises yeah the country change was a
surprise the marriage was not a surprise
we planned
apart from everything else everything
was a surprise now i said i like
surprises
so i can roll with it but my point is
that's a lot of transitioning
so much transition and i felt the burden
of being in a new city where we had no
family we had no friends
and my wife who loves being around her
family and
no one understands just how close she is
to them
i felt this burden on me that i had
taken away
her time with her family and now she was
alone so i was going out to work
and she'd be crying at home and i was
thinking she's got no friends she's got
no support and i know you can relate to
this with moving and relationships and
so much going on
and so it's like i'm dealing with that
and guess what six months later
i have to leave and move on and work on
a new career to build everything myself
and then i'm four months away from being
broke
and so on top of all of this i've now
got four months away from being broke
i've got enough money money to save for
four months to pay for rent and
groceries and that's it
in new york city and that's it and guess
what even on top of that
i've got 30 days before my visa runs out
and i'm kicked out of the country so i
can't even live here anymore
so not only have i just got married
moved job three times changed career
again
had to move into apartment four months
of being broke and i might get kicked
out in 30 days
and my renewal for my visa costs fifteen
thousand dollars oh
so that's going to eat into those four
months i have probably
never been under that much emotional
physical and and mental pressure in my
life like genuinely i
felt it and i thought my body changed my
my breath
was more stressed i would be breathing
shorter shorter breaths
not deep breaths heartbeating faster not
working out you get into lazy habits you
start craving junk food
i'm living in a 500 square foot
apartment with my wife which is which is
tiny like everything's in that space and
guess what we both work from home
so i'm now sitting at a desk hunched
over trying to figure stuff out
she's trying to cook in the same room
like i'm trying to just just try to
figure out what to do and i remember the
next morning
sending like a hundred emails to people
and just being like
this is who i am this is what i can do
how can we serve and that was the same
year that i ended up meeting you later
in that year
and the beginning three months of that
journey was
so stressful like they were so stressful
because i was like
what if i have to move back to london
what am i going to say to her parents i
mean i just took their daughter away
like
i just got married i've lived in new
york city for six months and my life's
falling apart like you know so much and
i've got all these views but
there's nothing there's nothing
happening and we met also you also
i mean at this time you're also growing
so much how are you able to create
and reach this impact with your videos
as that's growing
while you're under so much stress and
uncertainty and i stopped a bit of that
time like things slowed down
like things slowed down i remember i
wasn't creating as much as i was because
i don't enjoy creating from stress or
pressure
and i don't think you can really create
something from stress and pressure so
we really slowed down at that time and
when i was creating
i was creating from a place of
recognizing that
i could share what i had learned and
what i had grown in so far
so anything i was sharing was like this
is what i've learned so far so that was
the biggest pain that i've been through
in the last seven years for sure and
all i can say is that i remember coming
home
to my wife knowing that this was gonna
be the truth and i came and i said to i
said to her i guarantee you this is
gonna be the best thing that ever
happened to us
what the pain the pain i said that till
the night i came home and then she gave
out so i literally came up i looked in
the eyes and go this is the scenario
and i just want you to know that i
guarantee you this is the best thing
that's ever going to happen to us
and i said this is this is a monk
statement that we used to repeat i said
i'm just not going to judge the moment
don't judge the moment because what we
do is we try to
label moments as good or bad and when
you label a moment as bad
it now does not have the opportunity to
become good
i'll give an example if i go i don't
like this book this book's bad right
and i don't and i love this book but if
i say that guess what i will never pick
it up and recognize the value that's
inside of it because you've labeled it
yes
and we label stuff like we label oh that
restaurant's bad but when you label them
that person's bad now you can't learn
from that person oh great one that's a
really good one
as soon as you start labeling people or
anything is good or bad
you limit it you stop it from being
something else and here's the truth
every moment can evolve into being
anything if you give it the opportunity
to
right but as soon as you say it's got no
value anymore
you lose it and so for me i had to say
to myself
don't judge the moment and i'd keep
repeating that don't judge where you're
at
don't judge what's happening yeah don't
judge it as negative don't don't just
start saying it's negative because guess
what we've all been in positions
where a gift turned into a curse and a
curse turned into a gift it's true
right we've always our dreams came true
and it ended up not being what we wanted
exactly it fell apart and it led us into
the
our dream tony why is it that so many
people that win the lottery
yeah go broke yeah gifts can turn into
curses too
but because we label them as the best
moment in our life or the worst moment
in our life
whereas when you approach things to
neutrality and just what you have on the
table
you can be like okay what am i going to
do next the way i see it is that
competition in and of itself
is not good or bad and and this is like
the monk mindset on 99
of things that this mug is not good or
bad it can be filled with water
or it could be filled with poison yes
and so competition i'll give you an
example
as monks our competition is in how much
love and respect we showed to each other
that's your confidence
that's what you compete on or how long
can we meditate for no no no
i can meditate longer than you so if any
monk is hit and i did this
plenty of times really if i sat there
and i thought oh yeah look at him he's
scratching his back he got out like he
moved
your meditation just got destroyed all
the value and so
monks will never ask how long you
meditate they focus on how deep you
meditate and someone who meditates deep
doesn't
go on about how deep it was but but you
compete
for showing respect you compete for
serving each other you compete for how
well you can collaborate
and i feel like you live this yes like i
i i feel like you haven't
you used to do that yeah but you did it
now like you think like a monk like i
feel like
we're always trying to find a way where
we can be better friends to each other
and support each other
and so you're competing on that and and
that's a positive competition that i
think you can have so you can still
use and this is the beautiful thing
about the monk mindset you can use
any yeah thing in a positive way
everyone you love and respect and look
up to
that's been their path and i think
that's what's given me so much that's
what's liberated me from it like steve
jobs is one of my biggest
role models in in certain areas of his
life and
when i've read his autobiographies
biography story by walter isaacson
it's like the guy has failed so many
times yeah all of us
like most of us have a phone that's an
iphone or an apple product in our home
or whatever it is
it's like he's not worried about all
those times that went wrong because
he obviously won big in this area of his
life so my takes just
everyone you look up to whether it's an
athlete an entrepreneur a coach or ceo
whatever it is
they have messed up so many times and
just
know that so when you're messing up
you're on the path like you're on the
same path
right and and i yeah i encourage people
to share what they're failing at too
because it just helps something that
happens is you have to surround yourself
by peers in a space too who understand
you
and don't see you as competition and
that's really hard and it's
like a fine line i genuinely believe
that
collaboration wins always so i my whole
approach to most things has always been
hey i want to collaborate with you
whether i'm bigger on social media or
smaller on social media i'm just like
i just want to work together because i
think that's going to win long term for
all of us
both not just in terms of success in
numbers but more in terms of i want to
be friends with you
and so i reach out regularly to people
that i admire in different ways
and i reach out to them and say hey i'd
love to get to know you i'd
love to learn from you i'd love to
connect i'd love to be a friend like
not i'd love to for you to teach me how
you do this
and if that comes naturally from that
relationship amazing if it never evolves
into that i've just got a great friend
who now gets me
so i try and make friends in two areas
one is in an area of people who
understand my life
because i feel the conversations you can
have with someone who does exactly what
you do
are just so great because they already
get you right
and uh someone that i had on my podcast
lately her name's lily singh
superwoman she's become a recent friend
she's
been incredibly and is incredibly
successful on social media
she's using her platform for doing
amazing good in the world
and she was someone i reached out to
because i was just like hey like
you've been doing all of this for a
while you started on youtube a lot
longer than i did
and i would just love to connect from
you and hear from you and she's
become an incredible friend and we've
just been sharing ideas and learning
together and it's like that
relationship's awesome and then at the
same time i'm trying to find people who
are not in media
so i still have friendships with the
monks back in india and i just spent
january in india for a month i was
meditating again for
for roughly about 21 days and i have
them in my life because they remind me
of like the roots
and they remind me of the truths that
bring me back so i kind of like both i
love people who totally get my space
and usually those are people i reach out
to and then i love
having my roots down so most of my inner
circle now is from people i've reached
out to
or they become people who've been
reaching out to me for a long long time
and have been consistently reaching out
to me asking for nothing
we all feel that rejection kills dreams
we all feel that failure kills dreams we
all feel that
people kill dreams you can't kill my
dreams
but actually there's four words that we
say in our heads
to ourselves that genuinely have
destroyed
more dreams than all of those things put
together
those four words are what will
people say what will people say how many
times
have you stopped yourself from doing
something because you're scared of how
people will react
how many times out of the fear of
someone else's opinion or criticism
have you stopped yourself from doing
what you believe in
how many times has someone's perception
or perspective
stopped you from living your potential
no matter
what you choose to do there will always
be people who find
fault with it there will always be
people who criticize complain
who try to bring you down and tell you
that what you're doing
isn't right haters gonna hate it's crazy
that we
give up what we most want in life just
based on people's opinions
and the crazy thing is if we're living
for other people's opinions
we'll never be right there'll always be
someone with
something that they won't agree with and
this is why it's so important that we
work with our own conviction
we work on what matters to us it was
aristotle who told us that there were
only three ways
to avoid criticism do nothing say
nothing
be nothing and i'm sure none of us want
that of our future
when we die our lifeline does this right
it looks like this
when you're living your lifeline's doing
this
notice how that connects with our real
experience of life
real life is ups and downs
stagnant life death looks like this
being an entrepreneur looks like this
one's living one's dead you choose when
i saw that i started to visualize that
i realized that every time i failed
every time things went wrong every time
i chose to risk to live my passion
and things didn't work out and they
don't work out even now they don't work
out
and when i analyze the lives of
entrepreneurs and look at how things
haven't worked out
i just remind myself that's living
that's not
if you're a musician serve if you're a
coder
serve if you're a orchestra leader serve
if you're a
entrepreneur serve like make your life
about service
and helping other people not just to
feel good but make that the reason why
you do what you do
don't make that what happens because you
have money
make that the reason you do what you do
yeah and if people start with
service then you'll experience love then
you'll experience compassion
then you'll experience gratitude
services gandhi said that you
find yourself when you lose yourself in
the service of others
and and that's the deepest level of
self-actualization so know that you're
the soul and the consciousness not the
body
know that you have a unique genius and
don't settle for any less
and use both of those to serve
other people as the reason for the first
i remember
this video that went viral around two
years ago where this young girl
around two years old started to crawl
and walk in her parents living room
she went up to the television screen and
she decided
to try and get it to swipe she started
doing this with her little hands and
fingers
hoping that the television screen would
swipe
to her complete bewilderment the
television screen
did not swipe oh come on all of a sudden
tears started to run down her eyes
because she in her two-year-old life
had never come across a screen that
didn't swipe
it doesn't work what do you mean it
doesn't work it doesn't work
she probably used her parents ipad or
laptop she used her parents screen
and she'd been seeing screen swipe for
two years but this screen
did not swipe in two years she had
developed a belief
that every screen in her life swipes
imagine if in two years
she was completely conditioned to
believe that every screen
swipes how quickly we all become
conditioned in two decades
four decades six decades or even more
they say that the biggest challenge
today is not simply to learn
but to learn unlearn and relearn
wait what so i want you to think about
in your mind
the one habit that you want to change
now if you truly want to change your
habit
psychologists and researchers say it
will take anywhere from 21 to 90
days if you want to change anything in
your life you have to start
with a small step but make it a big
priority
one of the biggest mistakes people make
is they try to make big changes
and make them a small priority i had it
backwards
i'm not telling you to not work at a
corporate i think corporate experience
is great what i'm saying is
don't lose this voice work till 6 pm
every day then go home and work on what
you actually care about
use your weekends to not be on instagram
and actually do what you care about
you do that you're investing in your
meaning you can be making enough money
and make the switch that's what's up for
all of you who have a great degree have
a great education you've got that job
lined up
use it just don't become a servant of
that job
don't just say oh i'm in prison now i'm
just going to use my weekends to hang
out if you do want to do that that's
cool too if you say to me jay actually
whatever you're saying i don't even want
that i just want to hang out
and have a good time i don't even want
meaning or purpose that's cool with me
too but if you want to be happy
and you want to be fulfilled and you
want to have an impact on the world
then use your time wisely i used to go
home after my corporate job at 8 p.m
and edit till 1am on my own every day so
do your job get a job if that's where
you need to go with it if you can't go
all in be safe be secure but then don't
waste that time
on not doing that and then complaining
that you don't have what you want
one thing i've been observing is that
achievement or ambition is broken down
into five stages
learn experiment perform struggle
thrive right now the challenge with all
of those is is that we want to thrive
all the time we want to be in thrive
zone we want to be winning those awards
getting those views getting those
messages getting those
likes all the time we want to be noticed
and recognized but actually if we took a
step back
we realized we need to be learning we
need to be experimenting
and so what happens is that we get
confused by where we
are and so our expectation of what we
want
is totally blurred and we start chasing
a false
reality and that's why we find that we
get disappointed and confused
when we know we should actually be
performing we actually need to do we
need to act
rather than chasing that thriving
feeling all the time so next time you
think things aren't working out next
time you feel you're
not on the right track step back and ask
yourself should i be learning should i
be experimenting should i be thriving
should i be performing or should i be
struggling and that one comes around a
lot more than you can imagine
let me tell you about this girl called
cleo i think you might know someone like
her too
she had the dream of becoming a model
she said she was going to move to la
to pursue it seriously she took care of
herself
at least her body well someone told me
she did ads for l'oreal
she had so many followers on instagram
who all loved her
within a minute of her posting a picture
there would be hundreds and hundreds of
comments
all telling her how beautiful she was
how good she looked
comment after comment like after like
she was a real entertainer
she was always making everyone laugh i
remember
every guy wanted her number but but she
kept to herself
she just had this infectious energy
she got along with everyone she was
always the life of the party
she was never seen in the same outfit
twice boxes and boxes of amazon prime
on instagram she was the perfect girl
with the perfect life
the perfect world with the perfect guys
but nothing's perfect right
it seemed like she was always having the
best time with her friends
always traveling new experiences and so
many great stories to share
until people started to notice i think
she lived like two lives
no one really knew her inside she had
everyone to text
but no one to talk to everyone to follow
but no one to walk with when the phone
was up her world was a stage
when it was down a reality came she had
an invite to every event
but still felt lonely she had all the
friends in the world
but still felt no one really knows me
she was going through pain
but never showed that side it was
something she hid from the world or
maybe we just never asked
she had masked her sadness with what
looked like the ideal
life she was always flying high in the
air
but felt low inside her inbox was always
full
but she felt empty within she was happy
on the outside
but struggling with depression and
anxiety
she had an addiction that everyone
called a lifestyle
but she was struggling with mental
health but people were just occupied by
her physical appearance
see people think depression is sadness
people think depression is crying
people think depression is being quiet
depression is when we smile but we want
to cry
it's when we talk but we want to be
quiet
it's when we pretend like we're happy
but we're not
depression is not always obvious she
drank to drown her pain but the pain
learned how to swim
she was sick of crying tired of trying
smiling but inside she was dying
it's amazing how we can think we know
someone and still not know them at all
i don't think we understand how
stressful it is to explain what's going
on in your head
when you don't even understand yourself
we use
filters to lighten our photos whilst we
carry the heavy weight of stress
remember it's okay to have highlight
reels but make sure someone knows how
you really feel
it's okay to use face time but make sure
you spend quality time
face to face it's okay to have followers
but make sure you have true friends
don't live for the approval of others
document the moments you're most in love
with yourself
not just the moments you think people
will love
the most when someone doesn't post for a
few days
we ask if they're okay when someone
posts
every day we assume they are tell people
you love them
be a trustworthy friend tell them that
they matter
tell them that they've survived a lot
and they're ready to thrive now
people who care will ask how you're
doing
people who love you will wait till you
tell the truth
and that's why robin williams said i
used to think
that the worst thing in life was to end
up alone
it's not the worst thing in life is to
end up with people
who make you feel alone so the monkey
mind is what we experience
on a day-to-day basis the monkey mind is
restless the monkey mind is jumping from
branch to branch
the monkey mind's trying to find a
bigger banana the monkey mind
is constantly just like feeling
flustered
dissatisfied or scarce and overthinking
everything
the monk mind is the exact opposite the
monk mind is calm and composed
the monk mind knows to be focused and
aware among my nose so
everything in this book and everything
that we're talking about is the
transformation
from the monkey mind that we experience
to the monk mind
the monkey mind is almost the enemy to
the monk mind it's the opposite
i read an incredible study that changed
the way i
create and think and it said that the
human mind
can't be logical and creative at the
same time
how many of you have ever walked from a
highly creative brainstorm where you
were
fueled with passion and then had to talk
about numbers and business and
right it's tough right anyone ever found
that quite difficult it's quite
challenging and the mind's like
trying to run from one side of the brain
to the other side of the brain
so what i do is i create in depth so i
go really
deep into my creation and then i go
really deep into everything else that i
have to do so before i went to india
i created my content in advance and so
when i was in india i was able to really
switch off
so the beauty of being able to be in
india for 21 or 30 days or wherever i am
in the world for that matter
i'm then not having to think of
creativity as stress or pressure i'm
able to
do creativity as a form of passion and
service and so when i was in india i was
able to not look at instagram
i was able to not look at facebook i was
able to completely switch off for 21
days when i was there earlier in january
and i started my year in the way i
wanted to so i was meditating for eight
hours a day i was spending time with my
teachers who are
mind-blowing and incredible and trying
to learn from them and taking knowledge
and wisdom from them
and continuously praying to be of more
service this year and make a difference
this year so
that's how i chose to spend my january
and i had so many people saying to me
they were just like
jay it's january things are going well
in your career
how can you take 21 days off right that
pressure
that noise of like things are going good
for you how can you take time off
i was like things are going good because
i'm doing this all right like you know i
had one of my teachers that has kept
saying to me for years he goes if you
want to move three steps forward you
have to go three steps deep and so if
i'm not going forward i know it's
because i haven't gone deep
so for me that's a big priority for me
and that's what i try and do when i'm
i try and do that every day but i also
believe in immersive experiences
so a lot of us today we live in this
world which is like 10 minutes today do
it for 10 minutes today everything will
be great and that is great there's
nothing wrong with that
but imagine you spent with a boy or a
girl your partner whoever it was someone
that you just started dating
imagine you spent 10 minutes a day with
them how long would it take you to
figure out whether you wanted to fall in
love with them or not
probably a long time and so when you go
immersive you spend a weekend away with
someone you know whether you like them
or not
and meditation mindfulness all these
habits are the same the more you immerse
yourself
the more you get an experience that
stays with you the more that you can
live with that experience and
keep going back to it for 10 minutes a
day so i really believe in immersive
experiences
i love the 10 minute a day advice but i
also deeply believe in having an
deep immersive absorbed experience
that completely takes over your whole
body mind and soul
we're wired for generosity but we're
educated for greed i think i just said
it to you two years ago when i was on
the podcast
it's like and when i said that and the
statement it was
so true we're wired for generosity but
we're educated for greed
because what happens is when we're kids
you see kids you want to share they've
got their way they want to share
my candy bar whatever yeah and then as
we get older we're told
that there's less and this is what the
key is as we get older we're told
there are finite numbers of how many
kids get made onto the basketball or
baseball team yes we're told there's a
finite number of college spaces
we're told there's a finite number of
how many tickets there are we're told
there's a finite number of people that
are successful guess what
in the theater of happiness there are
infinite
and unlimited seats and there is a seat
with your name on it there is a seat
with your name on it in the theater of
dreams in the theater of happiness but
you
think that because you think that there
are only a hundred people allowed in
that if someone else makes it before you
that you don't get in and guess what is
there a cap on how many billionaires
there are in the world
no no is there a cap on how many
millionaires around the world no
is there a cap on how many happy people
there are in the world no and that's why
i really am encouraging forms
i want forbes forget printing a richness
print a happy list of service lists
bring a list of who is we should do that
we should do that
serving the most in the world wow it'll
be competition
yeah sure i gave more than you get and
that's why it should be serviced based
on time
energy and money because we should start
showing how much
time people give how much energy people
give mother teresa i don't think she
gave any money to her charities right
but you get a lot of time and energy
yeah you know you look at all the people
who made a change in the world martin
luther king gandhi like
they may not have given a lot of money
to stuff yeah they gave time and energy
you don't have to give resources but
your resourcefulness your love
your loved one your focus your attention
your compassion
love that uh you know resourcefulness of
the of the heart
not of the wallet i think
and you don't need to have a lot of
money to make a big impact you don't
there's and
this is the training see we've been
educated for greed because we've been
told
everything's limited there's limited
number of this limited number of this
number and every time you play numbers
and i think it was bob marley who said
it but
every time you play numbers you'll
always be dissatisfied because guess
what someone's always have more
someone's always going to have more i
was speaking to a friend recently
and it's me and and this friend was
telling me that
he you know bought a home
which is very expensive very very
expensive and he went to a party
at someone else's house and he told me
that when he was getting a tour of this
party
he found out that this person had a
painting on his wall which cost the
amount his house cost
and so he was joking he was like that
that guy's
painting in the house he's got my house
on his wall
wow and and that just puts things into
perspective and you think about that
like and then you look at something like
jeff bezos and you think oh well he's
the richest man in the world but does he
have the most
fame no he doesn't does he have the most
beauty subjective decision does he have
the most
strength or power maybe not and so no
one has the most of
everything so when you measure yourself
by numbers you'll always be second third
fourth fifth in something
for me breath works really important
because i really feel that we
experience one of two things we're
either experiencing our mind
ahead of our body so everyone's had that
experience where their minds racing
and the body's like oh i'm just tired
put me back in bed or we experience the
other extreme which is
the mind's feeling really tired and the
body's having to rush around
it's the mind's like oh give me a break
but the body's like no but i need to do
this and this
and so for me breath work really
realigns
my mind and my body in the morning and
brings it back together
because when i wake up i can be really
creative sometimes but oh my god i've
got a million ideas of videos i want to
make and i'm like no look just calm down
the body's not ready yet
you know or you wake up and if you do
which i've i've really avoided now but
if you do look at your phone first thing
you've got all these messages coming in
your mind has to go from zero to 100
miles per hour in two seconds
literally like the fastest car in the
world and the body's just like oh look
just give me a break i just woke up
and so for me the passing of breath work
just allows me to align my body and mind
so that's why i do it
whether it's david beckham taking one of
his famous free kicks or whether it's
lewis hamilton
winning the formula one whether it was
steve jobs about to give one of his
famous keynotes
the most underrated skill was this
visualization
the recreation of images sounds
and environments before it has happened
is one of the most
powerful skills in the world a very
powerful meditation and mindfulness
practice
visualization has been used for
centuries to help prepare the mind
the body and the consciousness for
upcoming
challenges situations and circumstances
some of the world's greatest athletes
use visualization as a way
to prepare for big games the big day
musicians for their new concerts and
tours
and ceos for their very important
meetings
i noticed in your videos that you ask a
lot of questions and
i i would imagine that's an intense
something that you intend to do
yeah i believe that the answers come
from within
and we're not asking the right questions
i feel we're always looking for the
right answers not the right questions
and the biggest companies that we
respect today the biggest organizations
all came from trying to answer a
question it all came from trying to
solve a problem
or a question that we were able to
identify
so my work comes from a very simple
study that i read that said the most
successful people in the world choose
education over entertainment and the
most unsuccessful people in the world
choose entertainment over education
with their spare time so my mission has
been how do we spread
wisdom at the pace people want
entertainment and to me entertainment
allows you to populate the thought with
your own brain like when you watch a
character or a superhero
you can watch it from your own lens the
movie may have morals you may have
values it may be too much good and evil
but the movie's not deciding for you the
movie allows you a space
to create and imagine and grow so for me
that's what i want my content to do
is give people a space to populate
themselves see themselves in the
characters that i'm presenting
see their own situation and be able to
come to their own conclusion
just around two years ago i had this
idea i wanted to share
wisdom at a pace we wanted entertainment
i wanted to share wisdom in a way that
it could connect
resonate and deeply evolve the lives of
people all
over the world for 10 years before that
i've been working with
individuals groups coaching at
universities companies
and all of these opportunities but i
really wanted to serve
and connect with everyone across the
world i wanted to make wisdom accessible
to anyone who had one of these i have
one of those
so i was excited i had the energy the
enthusiasm
and i was pitching my idea to every
single company that was online
now remember this is before i ever made
a single video before
any of you knew who i was who's this guy
i applied to not 10
not 20 but 30 online media companies
hoping that one of them would like my
series idea
i waited a day i waited two days i
waited a week
i was rejected by every single one of
those companies
before interview none of them invited me
for a phone interview
none of them invited me for a video
interview none of them
even connected with me in any personal
way
that's rude i said to myself it doesn't
matter
let's see what else i can do to try and
make my goal a reality
so i tried to network with people who
may be able to give me a chance
i got one answer from one answer only
they said you're getting older now most
of the people who want to break into
this industry
around 21 years old just don't worry
about it
other people said to me look you need to
go get a media and journalism degree or
a master's
and then we'll take you seriously
literally i was getting rejected from
every single person i spoke to but
inside of me
i had this desire i had this calling i
had this mission i had this vision
that i wanted to share everything that i
had learned
were people out there i genuinely tried
every single possible method i could
to break into the media industry to the
point that the only thing that was left
that i could try was to start a social
media channel
and of course you know the rest the most
incredible thing is
that it reminds me of a really powerful
thought from thomas edison
he once said when you believe you've
exhausted all
options remember this you haven't that
thought stayed in my mind the whole time
what i learned from all of this
rejection from all of this failure from
all of these
clear no's was one really important
thing
and today i want to give that as a gift
to you me
if you have a dream you have an idea you
have a vision
we have to take the responsibility to
prove our worth
before we expect anyone to value our
talent
when i started crafting and creating my
own videos teaching myself how to edit
learning how to produce understanding
the mechanics of social media when i
started putting my
energy into that space that's when
people started to take notice
that's when people started to listen
that's when things started to happen
this is nice it's when i decided to take
the responsibility
for sharing what i was passionate about
with the world and not waiting for
someone external
to validate me or give me permission or
allow me to do that
that's what made the difference if
you're feeling you've been going through
a lot of rejections
ask yourself this is your deeper passion
and calling making you want to move
further
number two have you truly knocked on
every single door and number three are
you working hard
on investing in your expertise and
passion
so that you really have something
impactful to offer
i believe that wealth is beautiful and
brilliant it can do
incredible things in the world when used
to make a difference
when we use any wealth that we have to
make an
impact to use it to make an influence to
help
serve and support the lives of others
but today
i want to talk to you about a different
type of rich list
there's more than one one of my favorite
teachings
about wealth has been this you can tell
how
rich you are by counting the amount of
things you have
that money cannot buy there's a
beautiful quote by jim carrey where he
says
i believe that everyone should become
rich famous
and achieve everything they want just to
realize that it's not
the point that would be nice real wealth
inner wealth fulfillment satisfaction
meaning and purpose is a rich list that
every single one of us can have and be
on
i want you to take a moment to make a
list of the things you have
that money cannot buy maybe it's a
beautiful family
maybe it's an incredible partner maybe
it's a passion and a drive
that you've recently found and
discovered for yourself maybe it's a
recent experience that you had
that wasn't really about where you were
but more about
who you were with and what you were
thinking about the reason why i'm
focusing on this rich list
is because this list is something we
often forget it's not on the front page
of a magazine
it's not inside the newspapers it's not
on the list online
but this list is one that you can look
at every single day
to remind yourself how fortunate how
grateful
and how incredible your life truly is
how do you know your dream is your dream
how do you go after something that you
don't know
if it's actually meant for you or not
great question
i think the number one thing to do is to
build
the mini dream first so before trying to
go off on this huge journey of building
this
humongous dream build the mini version
of it
and see what it feels like so if you
want to be someone who travels across
the world and performs
travel to one city and perform if you
want to be someone who's in movies
go and film a short movie right like go
and build the mini version of that dream
because that mini dream is going to
teach you so much like i'll give you an
example
i know so many people who say to me i
want to be an actor
and i'll be like okay great well let's
make a short movie
and when they make a short movie and
they realize they're up at 5am every day
and that they're in the studio or on a
set till 10 pm and they realize the set
is not very glamorous
that they realize they have to say the
same line 30 times
before the director says that line is
okay they realize they don't react is
anymore
because what we've fallen in love with
is what the dream
looks like and not what the dream is
so my biggest advice to anyone including
myself has always been build the mini
dream
and the mini dream will teach you
everything you need to know
about whether you're ready for the big
dream it's the same as sports if you
want to be a sports player
wake up at 4am every day go to the gym
for two hours a day
like do the actual schedule
do the actual process of the person
who's already doing it
so i always say look at what people were
doing when they were at your age
not on the stage they're at now and do
that and see whether you love that
that's how you figure it out just on a
very small level it's
incredible the amount of individuals
institutions
businesses that have absolutely been
destroyed
overnight because people at the top
believed
that the way they've done it for decades
is the way that they should build
the future do it again remember you
can't get anywhere new
if you're always doing the old it's just
not possible
one of my favorite examples is about
this company
that had the biggest market share they
had this opportunity to buy an
upcoming business that business at the
time was valued at around 50
million this large company could have
bought this small company
for 50 million dollars they said no they
turned it down
they didn't believe that streaming and
online movies were the future
that big company was blockbuster and
their little company
was netflix it's incredible now when we
live in a world where netflix is valued
at tens of billions
of dollars and blockbuster doesn't even
exist anymore
it's incredible how many individuals
institutions and businesses
have had to completely shift transform
transition and reinvent redefine
and recreate themselves to remain
relevant and this is a great message
for all of us we don't have to change
who we are but we have
to redefine reinvent and recreate
our focus our skills our priorities our
abilities
we always have to recognize how what we
have is relevant for the modern world
and all the new challenges that come
with it if we choose to innovate and
disrupt ourselves
we can never be disrupted if we choose
to challenge and experiment and test and
try new things
then there's no one else who can do that
for us this two-year-old girl
was watching a cartoon in her parents
living room at one point one of the
cartoon characters
started to cry you could actually see
the tears
coming out of their eyes this young girl
grabbed a tissue
from the living room walked up to the
television
and started to wipe the screen
trying to wipe the tear of this cartoon
character
it was an incredible show of kindness
compassion empathy and love from this
two-year-old girl
she truly believed that the cartoon
character was crying
and that her with the tissue would be
able to wipe away its tears
it was one of the most beautiful things
i've ever seen and that was when i
realized that we're
wired for generosity but educated for
greed
when we're young we have this energy to
give
to serve to be compassionate to be
loving to be kind
but as we go through life when we're
faced with
people being extremely challenging when
we're faced with manipulation
when we're faced with people we don't
trust that also makes us
close up i gotta pick a cabinet to hide
in what can you do today
that can make a difference in someone
else's life what could you say to
someone today
that would absolutely change their week
or their year
what is the one thing you can do that
can truly
change the experience of even just one
person on the planet
oh i have to think about it my favorite
quote from muhammad ali
is that service to others is the rent we
pay
for our room here on earth are you a
motivational speaker is that what you do
i like to call myself a storyteller
because i feel what i'm trying to do is
tell the stories that we all live
and i was just sharing with you earlier
that i genuinely believe
that the answers that people are looking
for inside of them
and i'm just helping people excavate and
become archaeologists
and kind of dig in and find that through
them so i don't call myself a
motivational speaker
because people may watch my videos and
it may not be motivational
it may be reflective it may be
introspective it may be insightful it
may be emotional
it may even take people to a place they
don't want to go so
i love being sharing my stories as a
storyteller
simply what i do is make wisdom go viral
i have this fascination with wisdom
insight
deep thought and i believe that that
wisdom belongs to
each and every person on the planet yeah
and so my desire is to scale that
through entertainment through
storytelling through video
in a way that wisdom becomes accessible
relevant
and completely involved and engaged in
people's daily lives and
there's a beautiful story of benjamin
franklin that he had his
13 precepts before he died he had 13
qualities
that he wanted to attain in life before
he passed
away they included things like integrity
simplicity honesty
virtue etc and at the end of his life he
was asked which one did you not attain
and he said the thirteenth one and they
said what was that and he said humility
the reason why i'm sharing that story is
because
the way you overcome your ego
is to recognize that you're simply a
channel or an instrument
when you recognize that you're an
instrument and whether you believe in
the universe
whether you believe in power whether you
just believe in mentorship
you recognize that everything you're
giving
is because someone's given to you and
someone's given to that person
and therefore you're becoming a vessel
an instrument a vehicle for the greatest
powers in the world
and just being a channel for that and
that allows you
to feel two things one thing is you feel
liberated because now it's no longer
your burden
the second thing that it does is that it
allows you
whenever your ego gets in the way and
says yeah we're doing well like i did
that i did that you start recognizing
and you get perspective and gratitude on
the fact that no actually i'm gonna pass
this
whatever good's happening in my life
pass it to my teachers pass it to the
people that shared it with me
because there is no one who is self-made
we talk about self-made millionaires
there is no one that word shouldn't even
exist yeah
because no one none of us are self-made
i'm not self-made
all i'm saying is just that if we all
truly reflect
and we don't i don't want the anyone
watching to think i have to be
self-made because if you have to be
self-made then you're going to have to
self-fall
too yeah right and everything will be
self-self-self when you fall on your own
and you rise on your own
[Music]
healing is so not about getting over
stuff
and it's so much about getting through
stuff and i think we have this
mental block in thinking i need to get
over this rather than get through it
and when you try and get over something
you don't necessarily process the pain
you don't necessarily give yourself the
time
and the energy and the care to express
how you felt
and allow yourself a outlet to really
let go
yeah and that's coming from the point of
realizing
that regret is painful change is painful
but change is less painful than regret
and so when you realize that actually
the only two options i have now i regret
or change
and they both hurt but change hurts less
and when we recognize that then we
choose
to change we choose to move forward we
choose to let go of that regret
because we realize that regret's not
serving us if while you're writing your
book
if while you're recording your podcast
if you're sitting there going
i hope this is going to be number one
this better be number one i hope i sell
more
i hope i sell more copies than this
person who's launching at the same time
because that's the only way
well guess what now the quality of your
output right now has just dropped
because guess what you're now living 75
in the future and you're 25
right now and guess what this 25 is
gonna define that future goal and result
and your happiness and you're happy
whether you get the result totally
whereas for me
when i was writing my book and of course
i want my book to be a best-selling book
of course i want my podcast to do well
of course we don't do anything
for it to be lost like no one does that
but what i do know
is that when i'm creating when i'm
producing when i'm writing
that's all i'm doing see the truth is
that only two percent
of the world's population can multitask
now the crazy thing is where are those
two percent when two percent when people
hear that they think i'm in that oh i'm
in that two percent like everyone thinks
that they're in there
but most of us are the 98 yeah and the
truth is there is no such thing as
multitasking what it is
is fast switching between two tasks so
the quality is just dropping because you
can actually
you cannot do two things at one time you
cannot no one genuinely can do two
things at once i guess you could maybe
like
pat your head and do this and say yeah
yeah you can't do something productive
at the same time right or creative and
so what i'm saying is that when you're
sitting here going this needs to be
number one you are reducing that things
ability to be number one
because it now doesn't have your full
focus right so so that's the difference
maker that you can want to be number one
there's nothing wrong with that
but you can't keep comparing what number
one is to someone else's goal too
because everyone's got a different
trajectory
like there are some people that are kind
of come in and do really well at one
thing and you're gonna do really well at
another
and that's why competition has to first
be in your space
like don't compete in a space that's not
yours
right because now you're just trying to
be someone else again and you get lost
in your identity
exactly i'd literally experimented with
everything with my health even as a monk
and
i tried week-long fasts and i'd pushed
myself without sleep basically about
four to six hours a night
and i got to a point where i was like i
need to take care of my health i need to
make my health a priority because i was
so fascinated about mastering the mind
that i almost neglected the needs of the
body and i can definitely say that i got
to incredible places with my mind
but at the expense of sacrificing my
caretaking of my body
and i felt i wanted to go back and do
both of them together and so a lot of my
friends
will say jay you always look like you've
got something exciting going on in life
and i'm like yeah i do but that's
because like nine people told me that my
other
ideas sucked right and so like i've i
get
more wins because i get more failures
because i'm
failing so often i'm trying so many
things out so often
that don't go right and then everyone
sees the one thing that goes right and
that's how it works and that's the odds
for anyone that's not just me
anyone who's doing what they love every
day is trying
100 different things and most of them
are not working
but because they're playing the game of
numbers
something's got to work like that's how
i live i'm just like if i try 10 things
this year
one of them's got to work but if i try
one thing this year
most likely it probably won't work right
and that's the biggest challenge if we
just up our experiments
like you're gonna you know do something
new for every weekend this year
i'd say i was quite rebellious and
independent even as a monk a lot of part
of amongst life is
conforming and accepting authority and
following a path and those are all
beautiful things for people
who who like those things for me it was
a great training ground
and a great system of giving me
abilities and skills and habits that i
didn't have before
but then i really felt a deep calling in
my heart to want to share this in a
specific way
so i i kind of feel dragged to do what i
do now because it's so deeply
in me to want to make things relevant
non-sectarian universal
and accepting of all truths and paths
it's just it's just there
and i can't ignore it and i got to a
point in my monk life or i just felt
like i can't ignore this desire to want
to go and
spread this wisdom and insight in a way
independently in a way that i feel
will work and help people you know from
an impact point of view
and so that was a big part of it the
challenge is that
we think things
come with emotions feelings we think
things come with feelings and emotions
and guess what they don't so if you
chase money
well they might for a moment right or
they won't i don't think they even do
it's such a false sense of feeling i
don't know maybe for a moment but it's
so short-lived
that it's it's not even worth counting
almost so it's like
when you when you think that i'm chasing
money guess what you will get money
yep and that's great money is really
important and money is a really
important resource
but guess what money is not now going to
fill that gap that void that feeling
that emotion that you're missing in your
life
what are most people missing we're
missing a deep sense of love i think i
think the biggest need in the world
as we've heard many times before from
all the ancient texts they they
summarize it like this to love and be
loved
like that is the need of humanity to
love and be loved and when we don't
experience that
we then start looking for status we then
start looking for money then we then
start looking for recognition
just to help us give the feeling a false
sense of love correct
and the challenge is because most of us
didn't experience that from our parents
and this is the key thing what we crave
in life
is what we did or didn't get from our
parents
what our parents did give us is what we
continue to crave
or what they didn't give us is what we
continue to crave so you'll find that
most people's love languages
that they chase are things that their
parents didn't give them
so if their parents didn't give them
time they now crave everyone's time if
their parents didn't give them
gifts they'd crave gifts if their
parents didn't give them acts of service
they're craving those acts of service so
it's because of our childhood
and if we don't learn to process all of
that experience which most people never
get the time to do
and i empathize with that because i've
had to go through that i've seen me
repeating my parents patterns was the
thing you were craving
so i would crave a big thing for me was
i would crave
surprises and gifts because that's your
thing yeah that's my thing still is your
thing they still might be
yeah and and i did your parents not do
that for you no they didn't my mom did a
lot of it
that's why you're still craving correct
so my mom would always
every year on my birthday she'd always
surprise me with the one thing i wanted
and i wasn't spoiled growing up i didn't
have a lot growing up but she would get
that one thing whether it was like a
power rangers toy
or whether it was whatever it was you
know something yeah yeah the thing is
you want as a kid right
and she would always surprise me with
that and that became so deep rooted now
i'll give you an example when i then
married my wife
you just expect people to know that that
they're going to do the same thing
totally and should not do that no
because i'm expecting my wife to be like
my mom
in the sense of i expected a surprise or
show me love in the same way
and she doesn't know that she's not a
mind reader i can't explain expected to
know that
so it took communication it took time
for me to explain that so anyway
i think that's where it stems from that
desire
it doesn't come from any you can say it
comes from society and education of
course it does but i think the deepest
place it comes
is what your parents did or didn't give
you that's that's where it comes from
now i've seen some stories about some
phenomenal
paralympians i've seen some phenomenal
stories about
human beings who without arms and legs
have achieved
extraordinary feats and this blows my
mind because i always think like
it's some of us have challenges in
different areas but imagine being born
without
legs or arms or you know like actually
not having stuff that
we all take for granted but those are
like
for some people that would be an
absolute dream to have that now through
robotics and bionic limbs they can have
that
but for years they've lived without it
but still seen i've seen positivity in
them i've seen
driving them i've seen a desire in them
to achieve something phenomenal
so it's amazing what's happening out
there we really have to connect with
those stories
rather than living in our small bubble
and often because we only live in our
small bubble
we talk to the same people right one of
the biggest challenges with envy
is that we talk to the same people and
they talk to each other
so our group is so small that we only
hear the same stuff and we kind of start
living as if that bubble of life is real
a young boy once asked his teacher
what's the difference between i like you
and i love you the teacher beautifully
answered
well it's like a flower if you like a
flower
you pluck it but if you love a flower
you water it and nurture it daily and
watch it grow
there is such a thin line between light
and love
and because of it we make so many
mistakes
in our relationships when we want
something in the moment
we take it and don't think any further
we do whatever we want to get that
feeling of pleasure
not realizing that we're neither
satisfied by that pleasure and nor
will that thing last when we pluck a
flower
not only will that flower die but we
can't experience it
for any longer than that moment when you
water it and take care of it daily
you can experience it forever we've been
wired towards an instant gratification
instant pleasure mindset all of the
adverts that we see
whether they're online or offline are
geared to driving us towards making
instant decisions for instant promises
of pleasure
the catch is not only does that instant
pleasure not satisfy us
the feeling doesn't last we're so used
to seeing all the strap lines and
headlines on the internet
learn this language in five minutes get
the ideal body
in 10 minutes a day become a millionaire
in 12 months
now all of these sound brilliant right
the problem is
they're not real they're not true
they're false promises
the reason why it works is because it
appeals to one of the most
basic human desires situational
improvement without major resource
investment
of course you can pick up a few words in
another language or
shed a few pounds of weight if that was
your goal or maybe you will make a
little bit more money
but real knowledge real
awareness real fitness real
business all of these things take time
real relationships real connection
real purpose takes time naturally the
internet headlines focus on the short
term
instead of the long term because most of
us would never click on something if it
said
learn the language in five years with
dedicated daily practice
we wouldn't click on something that said
here is the one
hour workout that you need to do every
single day
and we wouldn't click on the one that
said if you want to be a millionaire
here are the ten failures that you'll go
through in year one
how broke you might be by year three and
you may not even make it by year nine
the important lesson here is if you want
meaning if you want purpose if you want
fulfillment
those things take time i just sense
energy intuitively too
like i'll take a meeting with someone
and decide in a meeting whether i'm
gonna speak to them again or not
and i just trust that because my
intuitions i've been trying to
strengthen it over the years
and it's it really lets me down so i
kind of go with that a lot
and my my encouragement to everyone
listening is you have a powerful
intuition
you're just covering it with your head
so just listen to how you feel when
you're with someone
like listen to your heart listen to your
gut listen to your instinct because it's
probably usually right
don't let your head get in there and
make stuff up the thing is to get really
close
to that fear so what we usually do is it
embrace it get close to get intimate
with it
we've become the bat we're in the bag
literally yeah we embrace the fear we
run away from fear we like to run away
and go oh it's not coming with me and
or what we do is we hear one thing and
we define
the whole understanding of our fear
based on that one thing
so it's like someone and i'll give you a
normal example in a normal life scenario
someone says to you in the office you
know that you know that they're going to
cut a few people
and you don't even check you don't even
know and now you just made it real and
now you're running with it and you're
trying to run away from it so you're
trying to avoid conversations with your
boss
you're trying to avoid any conflict
you're trying to you know you're just
crazy you're just trying to avoid it and
so actually what you need to do is go
okay let me actually discover that fear
let me go intimate with that fear let me
ask myself
where's that fear coming from what am i
really scared of
what am i really scared of am i really
scared of losing my job
am i scared of not having any money what
am i really scared of and when you get
to the root and i call it the y ladder
in the book
so it's asking yourself what am i scared
of and then go
why am i scared of this why am i scared
of this why am i scared of this and when
you can't ask why any longer
you've got to the answer and that's what
you have to deal with most of us are not
dealing with what we're actually scared
of
so that's how you let go you let go by
keep asking yourself so i'll give an
example of mine
like if i heard that or if you hear that
in your office that people are getting
cut it's like you just get scared and
panicked but the question is why am i
scared of that
am i scared of that because i haven't
been working hard for six months am i
scared of that because i've been
skipping meetings am i scared of that
because i know my boss will probably
fire me first
or am i scared because i've been
performing really well and i'm expecting
a promotion
knowing which one it is sets you up to
build the path forward
not knowing that just puts you in this
panic frenzy
anything that happens from an external
item or something that's induced from
something external never feels like you
earned it
it never feels like you got there
yourself and hence you become a
dependent
person on that experience whereas when
you've built something
it's your experience to go back to at
any point
and the thing i love about that is this
is awesome
there's this awesome part in this movie
called limitless where robert de niro is
talking to
bradley cooper and bradley cooper's
taking a pill to be limitless
and robert de niro goes he goes you know
what you've i know you've taken
something i know you think you're
smarter than you are but because you
haven't worked for it
you don't know how to use it and
therefore you will fall down therefore
you will fail and it's
it's such an interesting and i feel the
same way that any experience that's
coming from
anything external we will feel insecure
when we don't have it
whereas when you've meditated and you've
really worked hard at building those
experiences and that discipline and
going deep
you know you can access that at any
point in your life
and that's the beauty of of doing it
yourself every day
we recharge our phones but we forget
to recharge ourselves let's just say
we slept well the night before which
means we start our day
with a hundred percent charge when we
wake up in the morning
we roll over and eighty percent of us
check our smartphones before we brush
our teeth we scroll through social media
we
browse through emails that takes away
10 percent of our energy let's say we
now have
90 charge left we then commute to work
we spend our day in the office in
meetings
interacting with colleagues finishing
off projects
and assignments we now have 40 percent
charge left on the way home we commute
through traffic
or on the train and that takes away
another
let's say 10 percent we now have 30
percent
charge left we come home and switch on
netflix talk to someone about what our
day was like
and sometimes we lose another 10 we now
have 20
charge left at 20 on our phones
usually the charge bar goes red we get
an alert
we get a message that tells us that we
only have 20
battery left the question is do we
notice when our charge is at 20
or 10 percent there are always signs
from our bodies
our brains our minds but are we tuned in
one of the best things we can do to
recharge is to exercise
the hardest part of any workout is
actually the 15 minutes
leading up to it we come up with 15
reasons why we don't want to sweat
and we change our mind 15 different
times
cnn reports that when you work out your
brain creates more serotonin
which sends messages to your nervous
system of happiness and well-being
working out for 30 to 40 minutes every
day
can recharge our battery by 20
meditation is an incredible way to
recharge
our batteries exactly what the gym does
for the body
meditation can do for the mind
meditation gives us
down time physically mentally
emotionally
and spiritually meditation also directly
impacts your entire nervous system by
reducing your body's productions
of stress-related chemicals such as
cortisol
meditation is a great way to recharge
and can take you
back up 20 we've all heard about
incredible morning routines
but the one thing that can make a huge
difference to your recharge
is your evening routine 35 of us
are not getting the recommended seven
hours of sleep
per night remember every body and mind
is different
make sure you find the amount of time
you need to get that serious
battery recharge and the 75-year study
by harvard
found that beyond anything the real
sense check for happiness and meaning in
life
was relationships connections
interactions with depth that are
fulfilling
and full of joy making time for deep
meaningful interactions every day can
give the recharge our battery
seriously needs what if we've recharged
ourselves
as much as we recharge our phones
because if we don't
we'll end up like one of our phones in
the bottom of some drawer in our home
so there's a book that i love called the
journey home
it's the story of a man who hitchhiked
at the age of 19
from america and london across the world
in search for the truth
and it's incredible because it shows
that desire is a true seeker and it's
got travel it's got
potential romance opportunities it's got
that sacrifice it's got everything and
it's just
it's a true story it's an autobiography
it's just a really incredible story
of how someone can truly seek the truth
and want to find themselves
and what that takes and what that looks
like so that book is incredible it's
called the journey home
by rather not swami it's an
autobiography it's incredible i highly
recommend it
and then the bhagavad-gita is the book i
studied as a monk it's 5 000 years old
it's the story of
a warrior uh getting advice
from a divine coach getting insight into
life
it's been it's it's a book that's like
the classic of india
and today most knowledge that i read
seems like it stems from it like there's
rarely a quote or an instagram quote or
a tumblr that i find
that wasn't influenced by the
bhagavad-gita it's it's not the easiest
read
but it's incredible if you dive into it
with someone who knows it well
so we're actually creating bubbles of
reality
that are almost illusion-like somewhat
inception-like we're almost creating a
dream within a dream within a dream and
you get so
lost in that definition of success that
you forget
a broader higher perspective definition
of success does that resonate does that
make sense
that often what happens is that we're so
in our closed groups we don't open up to
what's actually happening outside
in the world so i'm talking about these
people with robotic arms and legs
bionic arms and legs people who
paralympians who are
proving phenomenal things without even
having limbs can you imagine that it's
an amazing achievement definitely take a
look at it
and it makes us immediately feel more
grateful for what we have
here's the shocking truth about
loneliness
this is why we need to take it more
seriously surveys show
one out of three adults are lonely and
the health impacts of loneliness
are shocking studies have shown that
people who are lonely
are 50 more likely to die before their
time
researchers show that loneliness is as
damaging to our health
as not smoking one not two but 15
cigarettes per day
only around half of americans say they
have meaningful
face face-to-face interactions with a
loved one family or friend
every single day members of generation c
say they are the loneliest generation
and experience more health problems as a
result of it
loneliness was also linked with less
physical activity
compulsive use of digital technology and
not being able to share our problems
with others
in a study of 20 000 adults
54 say that they don't know one person
that knows them well
additionally 56 of people said
that the people they surround themselves
with are not necessarily
with them and approximately 40
said that they lack companionship don't
have meaningful relationships
and feel isolated all of us have been in
a crowd
that felt lonely all of us have been
invited to a party
but wanted to leave all of us have likes
on social media
but don't feel loved in real life so
many of us can get comments on our posts
but can't get a friend to call us back
loneliness is real
so here's what we have to do after
studying over 2
500 consumers over six years research
found that people that see material
possessions
as a sign of success felt more lonely
investing our money in experience rather
than things
is a great way of breaking the
loneliness and materialism
cycle schedule a time each day to talk
to a friend
take a class to learn something new
volunteer to deepen your sense of
purpose spend time with people who look
more like your future
than your past the mental health charity
mind cites two factors that can cause
loneliness
someone either not having enough social
contact
or more interestingly being surrounded
by people
but not feeling understood loved or
cared for
notice it's not just being around people
but being understood it's not just being
invited and present
but feeling like you're contributing
loneliness really comes then
from a lack of significance or lack of
worth
and what you bring to the table and what
value you truly
offer lonely is not being alone
it's the feeling that no one loves you
so start by loving yourself start
with compassion right
just start with compassion
one of the worst things we can do to
ourselves is
judge ourselves when we use critical
judgment on ourselves when we start
looking down on ourselves when we feel
that we're
bad people for feeling this way we're
only pushing away our inner voice
and making it feel more quiet we do that
to ourselves all the time when you judge
yourself and you think
i'm such a bad person for feeling like
this immediately you're stopping
yourself
from growth whenever you feel any
thought in the mind remember envy
jealousy
greed anger these aren't you right
they are all figments they are all
aspects they're all
facets or behaviors of our mind you're
separate from your mind right just as
we're separate from these bodies you're
separate from your mind your pure
consciousness right
you you like knowledge you like wisdom
you like
having other people achieve stuff you
like seeing success
because we have that purity that's in
there but our mind is kind of like a
shadow that overcasts all of that and
then we start
believing we're our mind when we start
believing with our mind
we start believing that we're bad that
we're greedy that we're envious
the truth is we aren't we aren't
egotistic
we've just let that shadow become such a
big part of our reality
that we've adopted that as our
personality we've adopted that
to how we feel so how does someone
find purpose in chaos
when they can't even get out of the
thinking because they're just trying to
survive
yeah so a beautiful question my my
biggest answer is first of all i
empathize with anyone who's been in that
situation having
i can't ever say i've been in that
situation in the same way but i've
experienced similar things
you've stealing in your life yeah in my
own way and i've seen my mom go through
stuff like that i know that my mom
worked really hard to raise
me and my sister while working you know
while running around and i've
i've seen my mom be that incredible
powerhouse of a person
and the main thing i would say is what
you can do right now
is find meaning in what you do make what
you
do meaningful passionate and purposeful
you don't need to suddenly look to
become an entrepreneur or
start a side hustle or find some more
time find meaning and the way you find
meaning
as you genuinely stop press pause for a
second
and go what am i living for like what am
i living for right now and if you're
living for your child
and if you're living to provide and put
food on the table
that is a beautiful thing that we should
celebrate more and sometimes it takes us
a moment to stop and celebrate that
and so i would say find meaning because
you can't always find happiness you
can't always find positivity
but you can always find meaning in that
position so i'll give an example like
i lost someone really important to me a
mentor a few days back
i can't be positive about that you can't
be happy about that
yeah it's hurtful you feel sad you feel
lost but guess what i can find
meaning in it because i can make a list
of every lesson he taught me
and make a plan to try and live every
one of those lessons wow that's
beautiful
and so if you're in a really tough
situation right now don't look for
positivity
don't look for happiness look for
meaning the word dharma means
a lot of things and it's always hard to
translate ancient sanskrit words into
modern day english but the closest two
definitions
are your true nature and your eternal
purpose
so it's almost like this is something
that's already
existing it's already almost part of
your dna
and part of your makeup and it's
allowing that to be completely unleashed
but i break it down
in the book to make it really simple
because just like you the amount of
people that say to me
jay what's my passion what's my purpose
so i use dharma to be described as the
word purpose
and then i create this formula or this
mathematical equation for how to unlock
purpose
and to make it simple and obviously
people can dive into the book and
do the questions and everything else
that's in there it's
passion plus strength
plus compassion equals purpose
and i'm going to say that again because
i love to break it down because i'm
going to break each of these down for
you as well that passion
plus strengths plus compassion
equals purpose or dharma and this is
also similar with the concept of ikigai
in the japanese terminology which is
reason for being
so you find these in a lot of ancient
traditions but now let's focus on the
word passion
how do you know what your passion is so
to break it down i've been thinking that
purpose is like an
adult passion is like a teenager
interest is like a child and curiosity
is the womb
so the birthplace of passion
is actually curiosity and interest and i
think we waste so much time trying to be
like what am i
really passionate about what do i really
believe in
that's going to take years to figure out
and i've heard you say this too that's
going to take experimenting it's going
to take testing
but the thing you can start with right
now is the simplest form of
what am i curious about what am i
interested in
let me take a course on that or let me
take a seminar on that or let me go and
try that or let me shadow someone who's
done that and that experimenting process
is the only way to unlock your passion i
want to know
how close to encapsulating the notion of
thinking like a monk
can you get like how like if you were to
give somebody just a nutshell notion
of what that means what would you say
i'd say it means to live a life
in alignment and what that means
is that you live a life where what you
think what you say
and what you do are aligned with your
true self
and what i mean by your truest self is
the self that was not given to you by
your parents
or by your education or by media or
movies
or not the self that you've created to
function in the world
so i think if you strip away all of
those
expectations obligations and opinions
what you're left with if you live in
alignment with that then you're thinking
like a monk
so i take out 21 to 30 days every year
to go
and live back with the monks where i
used to live in india so i lived as a
monk for three years
and every day i've made a priority to
continue my meditation practice which is
currently two hours a day it's been that
way for the last 13 years it's been the
bedrock and foundation of my life so to
that very big question that vishen asked
me
my first piece of advice would be
finding your
daily rituals finding your daily habits
finding your
practices that act as the foundation
because we're living in such
busy hectic crazy times how many of you
know that you have a schedule and still
half the things don't happen on that
schedule
right anyone ever been in that position
or how many of you go through that
process where you start watching
something really educational on youtube
and then two videos later you're
watching something about justin bieber's
mom right and it's like
and then and then you're like how did i
how did i get there like how did
how did that happen and and you end up
getting
lost in this world and so whether it's
in a small way of getting lost through
the content
you know rabbit hole or whether it's
getting lost by getting distracted from
what's really meaningful to you
for me refining my intentions on a daily
basis is one of my favorite
favorite habits i am such a huge fan of
visualization tell us i like that as
well because
it's gone the first time i started
hearing about visualization was when i
realized that
david beckham visualized free kicks when
he before he took them
uh lewis hamilton visualized the
racetrack before he races he visualizes
it
he visualizes himself driving the car on
that racetrack because he knows what the
track looks like obviously so he's
visualizing how he's taking that bend
how he's taking each part of the car etc
and same with beckham taking free kicks
and when i started looking when i
started thinking about wow that's pretty
cool and that was the first time i'd
i'd come across it and it for me it
wasn't visualization as a meditation
then i just thought this is cool
you know here are some cool people doing
it and then i started to do it before i
go on stage when i'm speaking at an
event
i'll visualize myself walking onto stage
i'll visualize myself saying the first
thing
so whenever i'm doing something that's
pressureful or anything that i feel i
feel stressed towards
i visualize myself doing it the way i
want to
first which almost reduces the
experience when you actually go out
there
because you've lived that life once the
next time you walk out there you've
taken away the stress and the anxiety
even if it wasn't a performance thing or
a high level thing such as lewis
hamilton
would you recommend to say you have to
have a conversation with someone
totally if you've got to have a
conversation with someone that's really
challenging
observe and visualize a yourself saying
what you need to say
visualize yourself in their seat
listening to you
and then visualize yourself as an
observer too so the first thing i want
you to believe
is whenever you feel an emotion that you
don't like about yourself whether it's
greed
anger envy ego whatever it may be
first thing i want you to recognize is
that it's like having a bad friend in
your room
that's really close to you it's a friend
who's going through some troubles
right that's what it is it's not you
it's like having someone else in the
room
who's having those experiences and with
that person one of the things you want
to do is start
with compassion if your friend was
envious of someone else
you'd feel compassionate for them you'd
feel bad for them you want to help them
right empathetic not just sympathetic
but empathetic
empathy and compassion is actionable
right it's not just feeling bad for
someone it's actionable it's wanting
to do something negative self-judgment
is the worst thing you can do
actually a lot of people find their
passion through pain
they find it through pain that they went
through pain of someone that they loved
and lost
pain of someone who went through a
physical ailment in their life or
something that they went through
and then that becomes their passion that
they've seen
the worst horrific type of pain and they
never want to see it again
and that becomes what illuminates their
passion to them
and so compassion is another way
and actually sometimes a simpler way
because we all know what pain we don't
want to feel again
and we all know what pain we don't want
someone else to feel again how many of
you
spend a lot of your days multitasking
okay good so a lot of us spend our time
multitasking now studies show
that only two percent of us
are actually able to multitask and
when most people hear that they're like
yeah i'm in that two percent
that's me right i'm in that two percent
uh you're probably not
i'm not because it's only two percent of
the global population of the world
multitasking is a myth and i find that
as spiritual activists as conscious
change makers
as change agents of the world whatever
you want to call yourself
all of us one of the biggest mistakes
we've seen and this was a quote that i
shared and a thought from martin luther
king that i've
really held close to me is he said those
who love
peace need to learn to organize
themselves
as well as those who love war
right those who love peace need to learn
to organize themselves
as well as those who love war i.e people
are trying to build
destruction in the world and
distractions in the world are highly
organized
highly focused highly data oriented
highly strategic highly process driven
and so we have to be the same and when
you spend time with vision you spend
time with the mind valley team
you realize their success is intuitive
it is deep
it is full of love but it is also highly
strategic it is also highly focused
and therefore it's effective and so for
me
my plea to all of you and to myself is
whatever we're going to do let's get
really strategic about it
let's bring sincerity and strategy
together
let's bring data and dynamism together
let's bring intuition and insight
together
right let's not let's not look beyond
that and think oh that stuff's going to
work out because i intend my intention's
nice
right your intention's not going to run
a mile
but it will help you run the marathon
but it's not going to run that mile that
you need to do right now
and so for me intention and action
intention and attention
both of them are required and so my
recommendation is whatever your dream is
whatever you're inspired by whatever you
think is going to have a positive impact
on the world
bring both to that right don't settle
for one or the other
the way to live your life in such a way
that there's no cause for envy is that
you've
completely trained your mind to be under
control of your intelligence and pure
consciousness you're actually able
to guide it now that will never be a
hundred percent foolproof plan right it
will fall apart
and that's what the only way to do it is
to be able to substitute
or train the thoughts of the mind every
time it goes off
to feel envious hence start with
compassion
then lead with gratitude when you become
grateful for what you have
you won't become envious for other
peoples i would put this quote on social
media for this session that envy is the
art
of counting others blessings and not
your own
so when we're in that habit of gratitude
of counting our blessings of focusing on
what's really working for us
that is where we need to start how have
you related to deep
spiritual learning and at the same time
being happy and content in the
material world without going crazy
interesting question
i think that's this point of spiritual
training
so it's like when we're when we're
immature in our spiritual learning we're
just starting out
when you first learn the first everyone
remember the first time they learned
something
and they were like i'm never talking to
my family ever again right it's like
because you learn a little bit and you
go
oh my god i've been doing it all wrong
and now i can't talk to that person i
can't ever go to that event again and
you start making all these
big decisions based on something small
that you've learned
and so i think in the beginning of our
lives because to protect ourselves which
is a very normal desire and very good
and very human
we think okay i need to take care of
this so now i'm going to shut out from
all of this
but as we grow we realize we can give
more back
and so one of the ways i've always
thought about it is
if you look at the ocean and you see
someone drowning
you want to help them but if you go in
too
soon and you're not strong enough it's
likely that you're going to get pulled
in
and at that point it's easier to shout
out to a lifeguard who can come along
who's trained who's disciplined who's
committed who can go and make a
difference
and so for me in my life i'm always
looking at if i can't bring someone up
i'm not going to spend time with them if
they're going to pull me down
and it's drawing that line for me so if
i've been ever scared about my spiritual
rather than putting them down and going
oh i'm not spending time with them
because i'm putting them down
if i can't lift them up then i'm going
to protect myself by not being dragged
down
but if i can pull them up if i can lift
them up
then that's when i'm able to go into
that space and make an impact to make a
difference and that line has really
helped me
not go crazy because now i'm not doing
it based on a judgment of them
i'm reflecting on my own abilities and
flaws
and and the difference i can make and
i'm taking a taking a stance it's like
someone asked me the other day what is a
complaint when we were talking about
litter
a complaint is you see a piece of trash
on the floor and you go oh la's so dirty
you've removed the agency that you can
have an impact on that
a statement is oh la's a bit dirty
there's trash and flow i'm going to pick
that up and
throw it away right taking that
responsibility
so when we're irresponsible in our
spiritual lives we judge everyone and
judge everything
and we mature we start looking at
through compassion empathy and
connection
and recognize we were just there a few
years ago
and that's the biggest anchor in my life
is recognizing that
i was addicted to and still am in
different ways
things that i don't believe are good for
me spiritually and
i was that i was that guy i was that kid
you know and it's taken a journey and
someone had to believe in me
someone had to invest in me someone had
to reach their hand
without being forced in and pull me out
and so that allows me to continue to
operate in the world i hope that answers
your question anytime you have a
negative thought that's the mind
right anytime you have a negative
thought you have a thought that's taking
you away from a higher principle of
collaboration
connection humanity anytime you have a
thought
of harming someone else anytime you have
a thought of revenge making someone else
look bad any of those things you
know it's that inner voice that tells
you right that's how you know
the difference really when you walk a
thousand miles in someone else's shoes
you realize that you don't envy them
right
robin robert she had this great quote
she said if we all chucked our problems
into the middle
of a room or whatever it is we'd all
grab ours back
right when you really look at the
struggle and challenges that people have
been through
it doesn't seem so attractive so
how can we find a solution to being
envied really
always be humble always be grounded if
there's people that are envying you
always express yourself in the most
servant leader format right don't ever
let them don't ever let it feel like
reality
be yourself be humble be grounded in
that way
what's been the biggest lesson in the
last 12 months for you
because you've learned you've created so
much in the last 12 months you've done
so many things
what's been the biggest lesson for you
in your life well that's a big question
i think i'd have to say that it's a and
i was saying it to a friend on the phone
this morning when i was on the way
to you and i was just i was just sharing
it with him because he was having a
moment in recognizing this
there's a wonderful verse in the
manusmithi
which i talk about think like a monk
it's a monk book and in the verse it
says
when you protect your purpose your
purpose protects you
now i wanna i wanna unpack that what i
mean by that is
your purpose is like a rare
jewel and a rare gemstone
and imagine you were walking around with
the most expensive
diamond or jewel in the world how would
you protect it you want to just like
you want to just wait out yeah yeah you
want to just wear it on your chest like
this like a baby holding it yeah putting
a pillow around a blanket you do like
yeah protect it you protect it and so
your purpose is like that and guess what
people are gonna tell you every day that
that jewel is not worth anything
they're gonna tell you that that jewel
is actually
valueless it doesn't have any impact on
your life they're going to try and take
away that value they're going to tell
you that there's another jewel out there
that you need
to have more value and what ends up
happening is you don't
i love the word look at the wording
protect your purpose
you have to protect it so what happens
is your success grows
you get more opportunities more ideas
more things coming your way temptations
but they can all take you away from your
purpose
distractions and to me i'm repeating
this for myself because i'm like
i just want to stick to what i was born
to do
and i'm so grateful that i get to do it
i'm so happy i get to do it and i want
to keep protecting it
i don't want to get lost in the waves
you know you don't want to just get
chucked in the waves of the ocean and
just get lost and just not know where
you're going so for me
when you protect your purpose your
purpose protects you sometimes it's just
what you're fascinated with right now
that's right because i think sometimes
we make it too big and we're like oh
well
what's my big purpose or what's my big
service to the world and it's like well
what moves you right now like what are
you interested in right now when
i mean mine was totally the opposite way
i grew up as a really shy kid i'm right
down the middle of intro and extra too
and my parents forced me to go to public
speaking and drama school when i was 14
years old oh my god because they were
scared that i was too shy and i was too
much of an introvert
and i didn't know how to communicate so
my parents forced me to go from my
school it's an extracurricular activity
i went three times a week three hours
every week from ages 14 to 18.
wow the practice the exams we were
examined
on reading a paragraph from a book with
tonality and
being able to bring a story to life just
through
words and visuals and then being able to
there was this thing called
impromptu presentations where you got a
subject five minutes before you had to
go in and talk about it
and you'd be able to talk about it and
you couldn't say anything that wasn't
true
so you had to make sure that it was all
factual and whatever you did research in
those five to 10 15 minutes
was right and and i remember doing that
and
i get to the end of that and i was like
oh well i've got this skill now but i
don't know what to use it for
because that's basically what i was like
at 18. yeah oh so i've learned how to do
public speaking i'm now
four years into my london academy of
music drama and arts and i've got you
know gold medal in this this this but i
was like what do i do with this because
i had nothing to talk about
and then when i started studying
philosophy from the eastern perspective
of the vedas and the bhagavad gita i was
like
oh this is what i was meant to learn it
for
like it almost like was i had a skill
with no service
sure and and i don't that's what i'm
saying if you're listening to this right
now and you have a skill with no service
don't worry or if you have a service
with no skill don't worry that's right
you know just go and find the missing
piece of the jigsaw you just gave us yes
this four piece jigsaw you just gave us
chances are you probably have one of
them yeah and then you can go and build
the other three
but don't worry about having all of them
now i think the two things that we're
all working towards
is a sense of peace and a sense of
purpose
peace is for yourself and purposes for
the world and i think we all exist in
both places
and i think where we go wrong is that we
try to live
life in an either or and this was one of
the most beautiful lessons that i
learned as a monk
the life was about self and about
service
there was no either or it wasn't
disconnected or divided you couldn't
live a life
of complete selfishness and expect to be
happy that wouldn't work
even if you look at like hedonism if you
look at it as a philosophy of life or
hedonism
however it's pronounced here but if you
look at that as a philosophy of life
which is
let's just accumulate let's just hoard
and let's just celebrate on my own
we know people and stories about people
who will not be satisfied that way
to just have you're one of them you and
lisa
and i and i can say this honestly and i
said this to liz the other day
are two of the most generous loving
people and humble people that i know
despite all your success and incredible
achievement
and that's what endears people to you
it's not what you have the ndsp or that
may endear some people to you
but what keeps the right people around
is that you both have these human
qualities because you want to serve you
want to help you want to support and
collaborate
and so for me i feel like we either live
and then we leave the opposite the other
opposite life is oh life is just about
giving
it's just about service it's just about
helping
that's not sustainable either and so to
me
i've discovered through real monk wisdom
that
life is actually embracing polarities
it's actually about doing a dance and
knowing
which way to go at the right time so i
believe as much in strategy
as i do in sincerity and i believe in
much
as generosity as i do in generating
value for myself
and i believe as much in giving as i do
in growing
and i think as soon as you start to say
no it's either or you have to choose
i think that's where we start to lose a
part of ourselves and that's why i
add that compassion to passion because i
know a lot of people who do what they
are passionate about but actually lack
meaning and purpose in their life
because they haven't turned it into a
service
what is faith to you faith to me
like the two polarities is the
day-to-day practices
and the map so it's the thing that's
guiding every decision
right it's the thing that's guiding
every direction that i move in
it's the thing that guys who i want to
be friends with who i want to connect
with the type of work i want to do
but then it's also what i do daily and
to me that's what's so beautiful about
faith that it can be
practical and simple but then it can be
philosophical and spiritual
yeah and so to me faith is both because
if i'm not practicing on a daily basis
how can it last
right and if it's not the governing
thing behind all my decisions
then how is it true like how is it real
and how is it your moral compass also
exactly yeah so for me it's both of
those things at all times
and so it's everything i do in the
morning so my meditation practices
my prayer the way i communicate how i
speak to my wife like i think all of
those things how i speak to anyone
i think all of those things are my faith
and at the same time it's like
do i am i doing this out of love am i
doing this out of service
am i taking this decision just because
it pays the bills and just because it
makes money or am i doing this just
because i think it will be cool
it's the same as it's so funny you asked
me this question because i was speaking
to someone about you just before coming
the show today
really yes i was saying one of the
things i love about ashley and why i
think we get along so well and we find
it so easy to connect is because we both
have such deep faith yes and i said i
always find it easier when you meet
someone who has their
faith and it may be different but
they're open and then you just connect
and that's how i feel with you that when
we first started talking and meeting i
felt it straight away
the people who are really rooted in
their faith and that comes before
anything else i always connect yeah now
i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know what
was your single biggest takeaway from
this video and your plan of action
for the next week when you watch a video
and you get motivated
the sign says you have a 35 chance of
following through
that's not enough but when you write
down what time what place and how you're
going to actually take action on it
you jump to 91 chance of following
through and when you have public
accountability and you commit
to other people that you're going to do
it it jumps to 95
that you will follow through so i want
that for you believe nation
i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action
for the next week put it down in the
comments below so i can celebrate
you i used to have a coach and i think a
lot of coaches use this or at least he
used to say to us he would be like
if you if you lose cry for a day
and if you celebrate if you win
celebrate for a day yeah
and then move on the next day get back
to training don't don't let go live in
the past
don't live in the past and what we do is
when we lose we cry for a month
and when we win we just move on which
means that our negative experiences
hold us back and weigh us down more than
our positive experiences
so we're actually allowing because we
don't immerse ourselves
in winning and growth we only submerge
ourselves in negative
yeah we need to celebrate also we try to
celebrate i've
been uh you know that's been part of my
life as well as like moving on too quick
and now we try to like
let's enjoy let's go to lunch or dinner
and really like appreciate this moment
and celebrate this moment and even have
a dinner with some friends and family
otherwise what are we working so hard
for 100 and we almost feel like
we can't we can't do that because that
makes us complacent
right but that's my point it's never
good enough exactly but if you win
celebrate for a day if you lose cry for
a day move on
simple if you want some awesome
inspiration from tom bilyeu check it out
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there now i'm gonna tell you a story
and this story pisses people off
and it goes like this my wife
who happens to be british